foreign
welcome to this meeting of the
mid-suffolk District Council planning
committee may I first all remind you of
some domestic arrangements please ensure
that microphones are turned off when not
in use please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
ensure
your mobile phones are on silent or
switched off and that your laptops are
switched to silent we will be using
e-voting for this meeting on the
modern.gov app so please could members
make sure that they are logged in and
ready to use the app
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of this
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film and photograph
or broadcast this meeting where when the
public and press are not lawfully
excluded
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via a far exit and
make your way to the assembly point at
the Ipswich Town Football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor do
not enter the atrium ground floor area
and walkways if you are in the atrium at
the time of the alarm follow the signs
to the nearest far exit use the stairs
not the lifts and do not re-enter the
building until you're told it is safe to
do so
uh so first of all I need to do some
introductions
um
we have the voting members of the
council are on my left we have the area
planning manager Gemma Walker we have
our legal advisor Ian Duprey who is
assisted by an assistant this morning
um we have case officers uh Bron Curtis
Alex Scott Jasmine wired and Daniel
Cameron who will be coming and going
um as the meeting progresses uh and our
we have our governance officers uh
Claire Philpot and Alicia Norman who
will keep all the I.T in order
um during the course of the meeting some
of the members of the committee uh were
also at the ward members where they're
not allowed to vote on matters in their
Ward so they will be moving um across uh
so we've got a case in councilor
hardingham's Ward and we have a case in
my ward when the vice chair will be
stepping in to chair the meeting
uh so can I move to the agenda please
um do we have any apologies for absence
to we now need to receive Declarations
of disclosable pecuniary interest and
other registerable or non-registerable
interests by any members are there any
to declare
Council hardingham
I should like to mention I am acquainted
with one of the members for not remember
sorry a resident in floating who's
affected by the
proposal for the assumption
number item number three decorations of
lobbying are there any to declare I
believe we've all been lobbied on the
summersham case are there any is there
anyone who's been lobbied on any of the
other cases
okay
is everyone got their hand up no
and are there any um Declarations of
personal site visits
nope
um now we now have a number of sets of
minutes to go through
um and agree now these meetings were all
held with the previous administration of
the council and
um a lot of the members were not present
at those meetings now there is there is
nothing to stop you still voting
um for minutes even though you weren't
there
um so you have the choice of whether you
want to abstain or vote on accepting or
or otherwise of those minutes you do
have a right to vote if you want to
don't feel that you don't have you can't
and of course you might all have been
watching on YouTube anyway
we don't know so first of all we have
the minutes confirmation of the minutes
of the planning referrals committee
which was held on on the 8th of March uh
um which is pages from page five of our
agenda pack are there any points
regarding the accuracy of those minutes
um could I have a proposer to confirm
those minutes thank you councilor
Matheson
uh and a secondary
um Council of War boys thank you
um do we want to do these fire
well we will do these as a vote on the
electronic system so the governance
officer will now conduct the electronic
vote on those minutes
thank you chair members that vote
grass
thinking members so that's um
four votes for and four abstentions
that's Carrie thank you
so that the minutes of that meeting have
been confirmed and will be signed um at
the end of the meeting uh now item
number six is confirmation of the
minutes of the development control
committee a held on the 15th of March
um are there any points regarding the
accuracy of those minutes
uh could I have a proposal please
councilor Mathison thank you and a
second uh
that must be me because I was there am I
allowed to second
uh and um so we will now uh the
governance officer will now conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote again
is in progress
thank you members chair that's three
votes four on five extensions therefore
that's Carrie thank you thank you so
those minutes have now been confirmed
they will be signed
uh item number seven is confirmation of
the minutes of the development control
committee B meeting held on the 26th of
March 2023
that that's not right wasn't it April
was she wasn't it April so this sorry on
the 26th of April 2023 sorry I thought
it was April I was there as well are
there any points regarding the accuracy
of the minutes
um could I have a proposal for those
minutes
thank you councilor War boys
um I guess I better second them again
because I was there
um so the governance officer will now
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members that votes in
progress
Council Lawrence are you okay would you
like me to take your vote verbally
um free thank you that's again three
votes for and five abstentions so that's
character thank you those minutes have
now been confirmed and will be signed at
the end of the meeting so we now move to
item number eight
um to receive notification of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme do we have any petitions
thank you chair yes we have received a
petition and respective application
number
dc2202118 land to the south of church
farmershimer and to the east of the
channel birstall the petition closes on
the 6th of September this year and will
be validated in time thank you
um so we now move to the schedule of
planning applications and I will hand
over to Ian to pray our legal advisor to
provide an update thank you yes good
morning Madam chair ladies and gentlemen
um we we've had an unusual development
that has been communicated as far as we
were able to yesterday we
respecting and intending yesterday to
proceed as item 9A with
um a planning application
which has just been mentioned in the
context of the permission
for renewable energy solar panels at
summersham and burst tool
there was a situation we were already
aware of that's made clear in the
committee reports that um
something had happened we we thought we
were in a position yesterday where all
of the statutory
statutory
applied with in the sense in the context
of a press advert a notice on the land
itself having been posted in time and 21
days expiring before
today when a decision could hopefully be
made that's still the case we were aware
however that a Consul an extra
consultation letter that was not a
strict requirement of the law but which
the officers chose to send out in order
to do a what they
to follow a job of public consultation
in a matter of this nature
that there was a delay in that letter
which I I will say is not the fault of
the case officer you're about you will
see on
the on committee
which meant that people were being
invited to send comments within a period
of 21 days which is slightly later which
ends on Friday the 23rd this Friday
we were proposing to deal with that in a
recommendation that you will have seen
in the committee papers
we
the the legal situation there is it it's
not a strict stature requirement but it
raises an issue that lawyers call
legitimate expectation which quite what
he
got what use of explanation we propose
to deal with it by recommending not that
you pass a resolution graduating
permission today because that would have
been unethical and arguably unlawful but
in instead delegated the power to make
the decision to the chief planning
officer and I would have suggested a
slight strengthening of it to say that
it the draft resolution said to taking
the cheap planning officer to take into
account additional representations made
in the final two days and subject to any
additional material factors to Grant
permission I would have suggested that
it was done with in consultation with
you and the vice chair Council having
him that's where we were at the end of
last week I had received chorus seen
correspondence from a firm of solicitors
representing birstall Parish Council
challenging the lawfulness of that we
acknowledged that and said politely that
we disagreed and thought we were acting
lawfully however there was another
development yesterday and that we
discovered unfortunately
that there was a further irregularity in
administrative error as we
in that copy of the environmental
statement the detailed statement produce
is necessary to be produced in an
application of this nature to which the
environmental impact regulations apply
the environmental statement which we had
from the applicant a while ago should
have been sent to the Secretary of State
and the council under the regulations
the council may not determine may not
decide whether to Grant or refuse for 30
days after that notification to the
sector of state and that's not been done
now it might have been legally possible
to amend the resolution and say we
because the the sendings of the
secretary of state is quite often a
formality the secretary of state only
intervenes in a small number of cases
but it's still an important regulatory
requirement that should be complied with
we've that I discussed it with the
acting monetary officer we both felt
that it would be inappropriate so asking
you to authorize the chief planning
officer not only to take account of some
late possible late letters but to wait
for another 30 days so on we as you
recall we spoke to you madam chair and
Madam Vice chairs today with our
apologies and it was agreed that we
would not
present the application the current
application undetermined application to
you this this morning after all with our
Apollo considerable apologies to you and
members of the public and recognizing
there's been some inevitable
inconvenience
late however
we still have underway
planning Appeal on respect of the
application that was refused by
mid-suffolk in February there's a
planning inquiry due to occur in August
with procedural time limits that are
pressing on us now
we need to report to you
in a closed session
if you will the advice we've received
from Mark Council who's been instructed
been briefed to appear for us leading in
junior Council and we will be inviting
you when the time comes to read that
advice in private
accordance with schedule 12a paragraph
five of The Local Government Act 1972 as
amended
so that that is where we are with this
matter again the officers apologize to
everyone for that
and I think Madam chair you you said to
me when we spoke yesterday that you were
minded to deal with the four other
applications
first and about that if I may say so
seems sensible to me too
thank you for for explaining that
um yes so um I I we think it's it's much
more sensible to follow through the uh
scheduled items 9B
um to 9 e
um before we then
um decide whether or not to go into that
closed session to look at the legal
advice that has been given to the
council so
um we are we will not be discussing item
nine a
um we will be moving straight on to 9B
um so uh if there are no questions from
Members about that
um we will
um go on to item nine B uh land at the
lease and Ivy Farm Ellis Road yaxley and
I will now invite the case officer Bron
Curtis to introduce the application to
the committee via the teams link thank
you
thank you chair good morning chair
morning members I'd just like to add my
personal apology for the uh the issues
that Mr deprase just highlighted to so
apologies to the to the committee and
also to members of the public we realize
that it's been very frustrating and and
complicated
um so this application
is one that has been before committee um
a few months ago in a similar format
um and it is a section 73 application
which means it is a variation of that
previous Planning Commission so planning
permission was granted by the planning
committee in February
a very similar scheme that you're about
to see
and this application seeks to vary the
detail of that scheme to actually to
reduce the the physical extent of the
built development so I'll run you
through the presentation
now
the application site is shown outlined
orange on this slide which is an aerial
view showing the main part of the of the
development site with sort of a square
shape
on the left hand side of the screen and
the tale of a temporary access which
leads from the a140 highway across
former Airfield land owned by the parish
council and then agricultural land to
Lee's Lane which is
you can just see in the center of the
slide here and then on to the
development site so for the construction
phase of the development that temporary
axis will be used that temporary axis is
in place already and used for the
construction of yaxley substation which
has just recently been completed
but during the operational phase of this
development access will be via Lee's
Lane the South
this is a wider view of the application
site so you can see Lee's Lane in the
center just coming from the edge of
yaxley
which goes up to the application site it
then turns around within the northern
side of the site and leads up to a small
cluster of Residential Properties here
and at this point Lee's Lane turns into
a bridal way right of way and heads
northward
you can also see the a140 and you can
see part of the if complex
on the right
this gives you a little bit more policy
context with some of the constraints so
you can see that Bridal way I referred
to or Lee's Lane changes from public
highway to Bridal way is also a public
right-of-way Bridal way at Judas Lane
and you can see some of the rights of y
network across the Airfield
you can also see some of the listed
buildings that are in yaxley and you'll
see more detailed listed buildings in
The Wider area on a slide I have later
this is your standard slide that you'll
see showing the red line of the
application site but also blue line that
is within the control of the applicant
this is the layout of the development
that's proposed so it's a for a
synchronous condenser which is a
specialized piece of equipment which
provides stability to the electricity
transmission Network the National Grid
it doesn't generate power itself but it
is a means of storing and providing
inertia for power so that it helps to
stabilize
um the the grid overall and that's
particularly important when we move
towards more renewable energy generation
because there are fluctuations in
generation with sources such as solar
and wind
so um infrastructure such as this
he acts a bit like a shock absorber on a
car and keeps the flow of energy to the
grid more steady rather than it being in
in spikes when it's very sunny or very
windy and then nothing when there's no
generation so that's what a synchronous
condenser is I'll show you some images
of of what it looks like you can see the
um the layout of the development there
this slide is included to show what was
granted last time so you can see that
two condensers were granted before laid
out slightly differently to the single
condenser that's being requested now
I'll just flick back
so that you can compare
those two you can see that this revised
proposal is to locate the built
development more centrally within the
site that gives us opportunities for a
greater amount of landscape mitigation
which I'll show you later
um I've included this slide from the
last presentation also because it shows
the context of the application site in
red there with the site of the yaxley
substation which has just recently been
completed and where that connects to the
pylon for the 400 kilovar overhead line
between Norwich and Branford
so you can see the relationship of those
two there and you can just see Lee's
name bottom
some elevations of what the development
will look like so the main part of the
uh the building it's an acoustic
building which is air insulated which
surrounds
um part of the equipment and it looks
like a modern agricultural or industrial
building and is quite typical of the
sort of thing that we have across the
district it's also very similar in
appearance to the substation building
which I'll show you in the photographs
in a moment and it's of a similar height
so the the actually substation has a
high point of 10.5 meters
this building at its highest point is 12
meters so they're they're a similar
scale and similar appearance what's a
little bit more unusual is the range of
external equipment which is similar to
what you might see in
um in electrical installations if you've
ever been to a to a bigger substation or
or something like that it's just a range
of range of different electric equipment
and the whole thing to be enclosed by a
2.4 meter Palisade fence which is
similar to the fencing around parts of
eye Airfield
excuse me this is the zone of
theoretical visibility which informed
the landscape and visual impact
assessment in which you can see where
the um the visibility will be will be
greater closer to the development site
and where it then Peters away and is
interrupted either by screening or
landform
um what's useful on here is that you can
see some of the viewpoints from the lvia
the landscape visual impact assessment
which I have slides on which I'll show
you later
and also on here you can see goswald
Hall which is a listed building
um just to the north here and I have
some views from that property and then
you can see just the wider context of
the rest of uh yaxley and heading into
melis and then through Anderson at the
top
um more detail on some of the
constraints and designations so you can
see the rights of wine Network
across the north of the landscape
as it passes close to goswald Hall and
then over towards the a140 and you can
see how that connects into Judas Lane
Green Lane and the bridal way on Lee's
Lane
so getting into the photographs this is
taken from Lee's Lane just up to the
access to the site so the axis is there
where the car is parked and the site
itself is roughly in the center
background there and you can just see
the posts marking the temporary access
on the right hand side which has come in
from the 140.
this photograph is looking over the
development site
just in the background there all of this
construction was at the time this was
taken was part of the construction of
the axley substation site which is why
that's all there I should make it clear
that no part of this development has
been started but you are seeing signs of
development in these photographs because
at the time we took photographs the
actually substation was under
construction
this is a view looking directly west
from Lee's Lane over the application
site so you can see that it is fairly
scrubby agricultural land at the moment
you can just see in the background the
construction site for substation and the
overhead lines
in which the substation will connect has
a grid Supply point
this is a photo showing the access from
the 140 so this is the temporary access
onto the um
former part of the Airfield which is in
the ownership of the parish council and
then heads off across the agricultural
land to the site
and then of you looking towards the site
from the 140 you can see some of the
screening here so you can see the nature
of the views
and this was the substation at the time
the photograph was taking it's now
completed but you get a sense of the the
appearance of the building which is
similar to the appearance of the
building that's that's in the proposal
before you
and just a wider view looking at that
substation building
across the landscape
and then these images taken from the
landscape visual impact assessment and
not of the site itself but they show you
where the site where the extent of the
site sits within the landscape so the
site would sit behind the vegetation
here
and
yes these are views from
the a140 and the old Norwich road on the
bottom
and then from melis Road
and from the Judas Lane right of way
so you're getting a sense that this is a
fairly high and elevated open Plateau
landscape with some intimate implanting
for enclosures
and these are views wide reviews again
from Green Lane and the right of way
close to goswald Hall
again one of the rights for a near
goswell tool and then over on the
Airfield
and then images from Oswald Hall looking
towards the site because there was some
concern initially with the earlier
application about the impact on the
setting of Oswald Hall and the um your
officer went to have a look at that in
person and assess that impact
so you can see these images looking
towards the site you can just see the
intervening vegetation
which has helped to inform the the
advice from your heritage officer
and then towards the site from Lee's
Lane
so again you can just see the substation
building
in these images
okay
just stop sharing there for a moment
um it just also to acknowledge the late
paper that you have from Anderson Parish
Council
and also to acknowledge that the leading
time for committee reports is is quite
long because there's a lot of
administrative work that has to happen
there was also a bank holiday and a half
term break in the lead up to this so we
did receive comments from France and
Parish Council on the 31st of May but
they missed the deadline for the report
being finalized which is why in your
report it says there were no comments
received because that was correct at the
time but hopefully you've had the
opportunity to have a look through the
comments from for Anderson you can see
that there are concerns about noise
um
the as I say the planning permission for
the proposal was granted by the
committee
um in February for a greater scheme than
is a greater in scale a larger scheme
than is currently being sought through
this application
that all means that there is a lesser
impact in terms of visual impact
toys
um as well as all of the other
considerations
we are recommending that we carry across
all the same conditions
as far insofar as they are relevant some
of them have already been discharged for
example all of the archaeological work
has already been just already been done
and agreed by the County Council and
deposited with the archive but we are
otherwise recommending that all the same
conditions
are imposed so that we're controlling
the same things and safeguarding the
same same interests as the decision that
members made before
thank you
uh thank you for that um I don't believe
we've got a copy of the parish council
comments in our late papers
um is it long I mean would you be able
to read it out I can read it out yeah
apologies I I had asked it to go late
and I'm sorry that that hasn't happened
so they have
an objection and they have four items
within that objection
they say the potential problem of noise
from the Machinery must be appropriately
prevented so that whatever the weather
conditions it does not affect the local
residents and there are franderson
parishioners within a short distance who
may be affected every effort must be
made to prevent noise from the plant
affecting them
point two a reporting system must be set
up which will allow local residents to
report what they consider to be
unacceptable levels of noise from the
site which will allow immediate action
to be taken to rectify the problem this
can be by phone or monitored email
0.3 all measuring and monitoring of
noise levels must take place at
different times of the day and in
different weather conditions so that a
baseline of what is acceptable noise
levels can be established this must take
into account the local wildlife
0.4 a maintenance system must be
installed that will ensure that all the
plants on the perimeter of the site
survive in all conditions
that's the end of their comment if you'd
like me to provide any information about
what the recommendation does and what
the submission does to address those I
can do that or I can wait for questions
um well we would like that at some point
but maybe we'll see what other questions
that members have got first if that's
okay so are there any um questions from
members
councilor Mathison yeah could you just
repeat that fourth point that the
actually Parish were making I didn't
quite get that one
the maintenance system must be installed
that will ensure all the plants on the
perimeter of the site survive in all
conditions
thank you
uh councilor had him
um thanks Braun um can you just um
reiterate that the pictures that you had
from Gosford Hall
is it called Hospital yeah goswald Hall
sorry
um
so you basically can't see the
development because of the vegetation
that's already there is that what you're
saying you couldn't on the other photos
you'd shown us sort of a little
alignment that the shed was going to be
or the building was going to be are you
saying you won't be able to see it at
all from the hall from the Heritage
that's right yeah you can see this is
the view of the towards the site from
the field on the south side of goswell
Hall so just outside the property and
you can see the intervening vegetation
is very mature you can't see anything
you can see a little bit of the pylon on
the 400 kV line which heads down towards
the site but you you can't even see the
next pylon where the substation would
Connect into let alone the site of the
substation or the development and then
um similarly from the garden of God you
can just see the tip of that pylon and
the next one in the row
behind all that vegetation
and then the window and the in the first
floor again you can see a little bit of
the 400 caviar Network there but
otherwise all the vegetation is
um
is good sorry that's the last one oh no
this is the one from the right of way on
the Northern side you just see the where
the extent of the site is within the
landscape but yeah it's very well
screened from cosmopool thank you very
much
any further questions uh councilor Davis
there we go
um
for instance correctly with this
submission you said that there's more uh
space available for landscaping so is
the applicant intending to give more
plant more vegetation therefore provide
more screening than in the exhibition
yeah what we're recommending is that we
have the same condition requiring the
details of landscape mitigation imposed
on this permission should members be
minded to Grant I'm just skipping back
to the layout so that was the layout
that's sorry that's the layout that's
been granted
and the landscape mitigation was within
the red line that is not being developed
you can see this proposal there's far
more land
available for landscape mitigation
planting so the intention is that there
will be more
on this scheme than there than we had
been able to secure on the last one so
it will be an improvement in that regard
uh councilor Lawrence
yeah just two points quickly on the
first one is uh with adequate
Landscaping
provided that should help the sound
insulation if it's done properly and the
other point is I don't seem to have any
record of the recommendations from the
previous application as I've missed it
I would just ask as their recommendation
for solar cells on the roof and if not
why not
uh thank you you should have a copy of a
decision notice in your late papers from
the last last permission that was
granted
um that includes a condition for so the
the building itself is an acoustic
building which is air insulator to help
attenuate noise there's been a noise
assessment which demonstrates that there
will be no
um observed adverse effect which is the
lowest outcome on the British standard
assessment for noise
um that you could expect from such an
assessment
um but in in order to further Safeguard
sensitive receptors and in recognition
of the comments that we've had from
local community
uh your environmental health officer has
asked that there is testing of the noise
level once the installation is
operational and should it be
demonstrated that there is an exceedance
of the assessed level then attenuation
measures be agreed with your
environmental health officer and
installed before any further operation
of the development so that will ensure
that the existing background level is
not exceeded so that's the noise that
sensitive receptors meaning households
already experience in that setting that
is the background noise and it will be
not it will not be exceeded by any
additional noise created by this
development and I should also say that
the noise assessment includes a
cumulative assessment of this
development together with the substation
so it's taken that into account as well
so you've got that additional Safeguard
of the the condition saying
um test it just to make sure that your
assessment is correct and when you do
turn it on it is as noisy as you
expected or as quiet as you expected and
if it's any greater than expected then
put some attenuation in to make sure you
bring it down to the level that was that
was assessed
um
the other question
I've forgotten could you repeat the
other question Council Lawrence
something another question was do the
recommendations require solar cells
fitted to the roof yes thank you okay no
that the reason for that is your policy
CS
or I think says that only
non-residential developments over 100
1000 square meters have a requirement
for installation of solar so there is no
policy requirement for solar for
something of this size unfortunately
it is something that your officers
outside of planning control across the
rest of the authority in terms of our
energy objectives are looking at
lobbying government on but at the moment
there is no policy provision for that so
therefore there's no
no reason that we could ask for solar
[Laughter]
make it into our late papers
um so I don't know whether we can get a
copy of that just maybe maybe
um Gemma could just check that all those
conditions are in that um previous
decision notice
um and maybe I think there was one other
question
um which maybe we'll take now and then
we'll go back to discuss the issues
raised by the parish council was there
another question councilor War boys
thank you Jeff uh yes uh in the um
application it mentions low level access
lighting
um is that is that lighting going to be
on constantly or is it good to be able
to be sort of motion detector so it's
switched off to at night so there's very
very little low levels of light
pollution
it's it's censored so the site is
unmanned and is controlled remotely for
the most part but there might be need
for maintenance visits and so
um the if if that happens during the
hours of Darkness then there will be
emotion sensor lighting for security of
the people on site
we do have a condition and I apologize
that that's not in your late papers I'll
follow that up after the meeting we do
have a condition on the permission
previously granted to deal with
um
uh Wildlife lighting
which would take into account any the
the level for ensuring
um Wildlife protection is greater than
light spill into Dark Skies so that
would ensure both Dark Skies provision
as well as safeguarding protected
species
yes um it was also about lighting so I
think it's been covered thanks uh
councilor Matheson yeah with the the um
the Landscaping condition did we um did
the previous scheme
um obviously had a landscaping condition
has that actually been discharged is
there a is there a scheme already agreed
of landscaping or are we just still
leaving that with you to um
sign off on something reasonable
we're still negotiating uh the
Landscaping scheme so some of the
conditions have already been complied
with
um drainage archeology but
um the landscaping and the ecology are
still outstanding
at the moment so they will be carried
forward if members of minded to Grant
they would be carried as to be agreed
rather than as already agreed
uh thank you
um can we go back now to the the parish
council comments about about mainly
about the the noise firstly
um and are they issues raised by the
parish council covered in the
um condition that was previously put on
about the noise what about the reporting
system and um uh you know noise levels
have to be within a certain limit
otherwise they're going to do something
about it
yeah so I've explained about the
condition which are environmental health
officers requested
um your environmental health
meeting to answer some questions about
about the noise implications and uh is
satisfied that that condition will will
do what it needs to do in order to
effectively mitigate any any potential
for noise impact
um it is also the case that there
already exists
um a method for reporting noise nuisance
to your Environmental Protection Team
in any case from any source so this
development will be covered by that in
the event that
something
uh unexpected which then wasn't covered
by the condition were to happen that
could that would still be controlled
capable of control
was the request from the parish council
more to do with reporting the situa the
noise situation to the
um owner of the site or the manager of
the site as opposed to the council
I believe that's how it reads I think
that they want want to have that direct
communication that the difficulty with
doing it that way is that there's then
no statutory framework for us to be
involved as a third party to
[Music]
um
to require any action it's it's based on
Goodwill
exception so far as they might be an
allegation of a breach of condition
potentially but I think it's
it's tidier to do it the way that we
have it on the existing permission and I
think your environmental health officer
was satisfied with that so
that should hopefully be okay but um
obviously take members um
resolution
and on the on the final Point raised by
the parish council about the landscape
maintenance for the plants and the
Landscaping
um is there anything to to deal with
that issue on the existing conditions or
do we need to have a new condition about
maintenance of the Landscaping
there is already a requirement which is
fairly standard for the maintenance and
replacement of
um planting that doesn't doesn't survive
within a set period of time that is a
form of words that has been through
case judgment so it's it's something
that's pretty standard for most
decisions most planning decisions
that also ties in with a landscape and
ecology management plan condition
um so we are adding that in which is on
the previous permission
to ensure that um that we're tying the
two things in together and that we're
safeguarding protected species and
habitats as well in accordance with the
statutory duties
thank you are there any further
questions counselor hardingham
yes
um in view of the landscaping and new
planting and the difficulty we have with
weather these days is there any
requirement for actual maintenance work
by way of watering and so on to make
sure that any planting actually
establishes rather than having to be
replaced the following year and maybe
the following year
I'm just rechecking the wording of the
condition
me just a moment
we have
a specification of all planting
including species size density and
spacing
areas for grass seeding
hard surfacing areas details
Contours boundary treatments
details relating to protection
enhancement of existing retained
vegetation and ongoing management of
these features over the lifetime of
the proposed use
and then
sorry sorry wrong I did just what you've
got B including cultivation and other
operations associated with plant and
grass establishment I think that might
cover those expectations but perhaps
some other words it might give Council
some more certainty if they want to at
that point sorry to interrupt Ron
oh sorry
that's fine I think the thing to bear in
mind is there is already a permission
that can be implemented on this site so
we may need to just be careful about
asking about too much more
um
because they can still just go ahead and
build the other one
um just just to bear that in mind that
these this is an alternative and
inconsistent permission meaning that
they if they if you grant permission
today they don't have to build this one
they could build the other one
um they only have contract from grid for
one condenser but that doesn't mean they
can't implement the other one and just
just build one of the two in in the
format that they had that's that would
not be unauthorized and there's no
requirement on there's usually no
requirement on any planning permission
for it to be completed
thank you um can I can I if oh there's
one more question from Council
apology says this has been nagging at my
um when the um
the construction access road is removed
the access to the site will be a long
lease Lane
uh from yaxley uh and it's got a little
note about access layout and visibility
displays I was assuming from that
comment that that
the lane will be actually improved in
order to enable access from emergency
vehicles and maintenance vehicles and so
on
yeah that's correct so there was a
little bit of um
complication with what happened with the
planning permission for yaksi substation
which came first out of all three of
these developments that we're talking
about this one before you today the one
that was before the committee on the
15th of February in the actually
substation the axley substation was
granted permission first
and the highways Authority was consulted
as part of that but they missed the fact
of the need for any works of improvement
of the junction between the main part of
the development site in Lee's Lane
they also missed that in their
consultation on the last application
that came before Committee in February
with the consultation that went to them
on this application they've picked that
up and they've realized that they have
never controlled that access
so they are asking for the access layout
and the visibility display for that
access to be controlled in accordance
with their standard their standard
measurements and expectations to ensure
safety of vehicles using the access
I have added that onto the
recommendation
um again the developer does have the
right to implement their other
permission which doesn't include that
condition and we have been trying to
work with County and the developer to
see if there's a way of resolving that
without the need for condition we
haven't yet got to that point
which is why your recommendation stays
stays as it is in your papers with with
those two conditions added on there
okay
um can I just ask about the lighting
condition from the previous application
has that been
discharged or is that one still
because clearly if you're going to
change the layout it might change the
lighting Arrangements anyway
yeah that hasn't been discharged yet
that's part of the um ecology and
Landscape environment plan so that's
still pending
thank you um if there are no further
questions from Members I will now invite
public speakers to address the committee
I understand that we have no Parish
Council representative uh no objector no
supporter but we do have the applicant
Mr Jonathan Cooper if you would like to
um have your three minutes I don't seem
to have the
timer
um the officers are going to get me a
really high-tech um hourglass for your
three minutes so if you just wait till
we've got that ready thank you
um so if you'd like to
um say your your piece um within the
three minutes thank you perfect thank
you chair and good morning everybody my
name is Jonathan Cooper I work for
comrade energy who are an owner and
operator of energy Assets in the UK
proposal in front of you today is from a
minor design variation to a consensive
planning application heard and approved
by committee earlier this year
the application is for asynchronous
condenser which is a rotating generator
with no connected load synchronized to
the frequency of the electricity grid
Network
its role is to support National Grid
during periods of stress by providing
inertia and short-circuit level which
manages faults and sudden losses of
power on the electricity system
as we transition away from from
traditional fossil fuel generation to
renewable sources of power
we lose stability on our Energy System
due to differences in how renewable and
non-renewable Technologies operate and
connect to the network
synchronous condensers can address this
shortfall by providing stability without
generation and play an essential role in
the transition to Renewables tackling
the climate and energy crisis being
faced on both local and a global scale
the original planning consent determined
in February covered the erection of two
synchronous condensers with ancillary
equipment and address the possibility of
a maximum requirement from National Grid
for stability services at this location
have now been awarded the contract from
National Grid for the provision of these
services and we've found the needs can
be met with a single synchronous
condenser
the subsequent section 73 application
before you addresses this change as well
as incorporating minor variations in
Access and Landscaping designs all of
which have been a accompanied by updated
technical reports
these reports have shown either an
improvement or negligible difference
between the original and revised designs
principally across visual acoustic and
land impact metrics the technical
consultants from local planning
Authority have supported these results
by finding no objection
in conclusion section 73 application
does not change the nature of the
development it's still synchronous
condenser technology which is a service
that supports our grid Network for the
transition to Renewable Power helping us
reach our Net Zero goals the design
changes result in an improvement or
negligible impact across the planning
consideration metrics and we have and
we've received no objections from any
technical Consulting notes in the
recommendation for approval from your
case officer we ask that members approve
the application and should you have any
further questions I'll be more than
happy to assist thank you
thank you are there any questions from
members to Mr Cooper Council Lawrence
uh could you just explain the life
expectancy of the sufficiency of one
condenser please because previously two
were designed or required would we now
be face potentially in 20 30 years time
for the need for additional which we
excluded happening this position right
in the middle of the site you may have
to go to another adjacent Fields site to
get your second condenser in
uh so we wouldn't foresee another
synchronous condenser being erected here
the lifespan of it's for 50 years and so
National Grid in their Pathfinder
process is called where they procure
these Services across the country
they've got three different locations in
East Anglia where the service is being
provided so because we're not doing two
synchronous condenses here there is
another one of necton another one in
Walpole so it's that same surface is
being covered by three different sites
so to answer your question we have no
intentions to erect another synchronous
condenser at this location
thanks yeah I'm happy to make a start um
um you know it's a great presentation
thanks Brian if you're still listening
and um
and I know I'm happy to go ahead and
propose that you know we we accept our
officer's recommendation and um and
Grant this
so that is a formal proposal I now need
a second uh
uh Council
happy to Second
um does any is there anybody who would
like to um say anything
um about this application
yeah I was struck by councilor
hardingham's question about the the
Landscaping the maintenance thereof and
perhaps not to try and re rewrite the um
the standard conditions um
on the you know on the hoof now but
um it does strike me that if if
Landscaping is significantly lost
say two years down the road
um all right so the condition says it
will be replaced but if it's replaced by
the same as went in two years earlier
you know this starts to be a significant
loss
um you know in terms of ecology and so
on and um
I do just wonder whether whether um
perhaps um Gemma could explore that a
little further as to whether for example
um
if it dies if the
H dies after two years
that that it's replaced with something
that's still already two years old if
you see what I mean
um rather than getting you know the
little Twigs going in from scratch again
um to just practice explore that that I
I wouldn't try and
try and write anything new today that's
okay
can you respond to that sir
thank you chair um yeah so I think a
couple things so yeah I think we've
heard the concerns I think we can make
sure that we're visiting the fact that
they are established and they're
supported in that but also to confirm
the requirement of the condition is if
they were to die become seriously
damaged or defective within five years
it will be replaced with species of the
same type size and the green location in
the planting season so yes that
expectation if you if it was two years
old it should be planted with something
of the same size and type that it was
actually saying yes
I think I've been we can always take
that away and confirm and make sure we
catch that in the Landscaping um
discharge condition thank you uh anybody
else wish to say anything
um if not then then
um I'll just say that that we need to
just remember that this has already got
planning permission for two synchronous
condensers and
um I I can only imagine that one is
going to make less noise than two
um and it does give the scope for more
landscaping and hopefully more screening
and that too will help with the noise
attenuation which does seem to be the
concern and as long as we've got that
lighting condition that is um as tight
as it can be to make sure we have the
wildlife friendly
um sense you know only motion sensitive
a lighting that's not on 24 hours a day
so if there are no further
um item anything any anyone wants to say
um can we just ask the planning manager
to read out the proposal and then we'll
go for the vote
yeah of course thank you so we are
looking at
um delegating authority to the chief
planning officer to Grant planning
permission subject to conditions which
is the time limit to match the original
commission the Landscaping scheme and
again looking at spaces with the ecology
officer the latest Lane access layout
and visibility space and the conditions
per the original permission which would
either reflect what's already been
approved so if something has already
been approved we would we would reflect
that over and other conditions from that
as relevant and necessary and then there
is also some informative notes about a
proactive working statement and County
highways notes so that's recommendation
thank you chair
so I would now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
chair numbers that vote is now in
progress so you may need to scroll down
to the light blue line
thank you members chair that's eight
votes four that's unanimous thank you
thank you
um uh We've now been going about an hour
and we've got another
um application to take so I'm going to
propose that we take a 10 minute Comfort
Break
um if that's okay and we'll come back
here at 10 40 please
um thank you
thank you
but thank you um we we're now going to
move to the next case
um which is uh feel to the rear of the
Crowfield Rose debenham Road Crowfield
uh councilor hardingham has moved across
um as he'll be speaking as the ward
member for this uh case uh and I will
now invite the case officer Alex Scott
to introduce the application to the
committee thank you
thank you chairman uh yes this is item
9C in the papers application reference
DC oblique 22 oblique zero three six
eight one uh feel to the rear of the
Crowfield Rose Public House debenham
Road in Crowfield and the application
seeks planning permission for the change
of use of the existing field to the rear
of the pub to a campsite and Caravan
site
and the erection of an amenities
building relating the site is
um approximately a third of a site is
proposed for the um for camping and for
the
tents a third of a site then for the uh
the static caravan units uh five of
those for tourism and holiday use with
an additional static unit for a site
office
is building and the final third of the
site as we'll see is proposed to be left
open as an amenity and activity area for
guests
a Central Access Road through the site
is also proposed with access through the
existing Pub car park utilizing the
existing Pub access to the public
Highway which was proposed to be
improved to current highways standards
so if we move to the first slide please
now this is the site location plan
provided with the application now the
area is approximately 1.2 hectares
that's three acres
the existing Pub
building is here
um
and the nearest neighbor is
the Mead which is over here and that is
approximately 150 meters away across
adjacent Paddock
and the cartilage of a grade 2 listed
building
um
uh New Hall is here
adjacent across the road however the
building itself
um is about 250 meters away
um further there and I've got some more
slides
to show that in a bit more detail
for you
um now there is a correction in the
opening paragraph I say the village of
Petra is 0.8 of a meter away that is
incorrect um
is approximately
um sorry 850 meters to the Northeast so
apologies for that correction there if
we could have the next slide please
so this is a close-up aerial view of the
site
Pub here the beer garden immediately to
the rear
um the existing access onto debenham
Road proposed to be improved as part of
The Proposal
and this is the field itself to the rear
screen by existing trees to the West
although there's additional landscaping
and planting as part of the
recommendation
and there is a public right-of-way which
I'll
these are later which runs initially
here
past past New Hall
then it crosses the road uh runs
adjacent to the site and then across the
site in this location
and then
on this boundary on this field boundary
further to the north emerging on the
a1120
through an existing Farm Farmstead
development along that road
uh if we could have the next side please
so this is a wider aerial view of the
local area
site is is here
[Music]
nearby Villages of PETA stonomassable
and Crowfield Village which is along the
road
here and just to point out the a 11 20
which is uh
build as a tourist route with a lot of
attractions
listed on assigns
great and I'll come into some more
detail about where those are later
that's it for that one if we could have
the next slide please
so this is a uh the planning constraints
major planning constraints affecting the
site the site is uh is here and there
you can see a bit more detail of the
public right-of-way leading past a new
Hall there and across across the at the
fields
the site is within the countryside
outside of any settlement boundary now
the nearest plan settlement boundary is
here
of Crowfield which is to the uh to the
south west
now the colored buildings you can see
are listed building and the orange color
denotes um they are grade two listed the
being
aforementioned New Hall
and you might see flood zones listed
there the site is actually within
environmental agency flood zone one with
the lowest um likelihood of flooding
approximately one in a thousand chance
of flooding annually
uh next slide please
so this is the southern part of the site
layout provided
closest to the road so again we have the
the pub here
the Beer Garden
to the rear proposed to be retained
and within the existing Pub car park we
have allocated parking here in dedicated
Bays to keep the Central Access clear
and there are 21 of those parking spaces
proposed for the campsite and the pub
and that is considered to be in
accordance with the Suffolk advisory
parking standards provided by the County
Council
says local planning Authority
um the access uh
improved
um
yeah it's advised and approved by um
County Council that's highways Authority
subject to conditions and you might be
able to see the visibility supplies here
uh within the land uh either within the
applicants control or the control of the
local authorities and those displays
would need to be kept kept clear
a height of 0.6 of a meter above ground
level and
consider that's achievable
and yes we can see the the Central
Access from the highway through the pub
car park uh gated access proposed and a
surfaced access road indicatively that
would be by a shingle although
additional information is requested by
condition to confirm that
so this is the uh the middle part of the
site so the seven structures here
you can see are proposed so the
amenities building here would be the
only
um
they'll be permanent building proposed
the other units would be static caravan
units
considered to represent operational
development that's built development in
themselves
and in accordance with the provisions of
the uh the Caravan act so they wouldn't
um not be essentially permanent but
capable of being being moved so there
are
five proposed five
temporary units for Holiday use and
this additional
static caravan proposed for office use
and that is the one which is on site at
the moment
so all units are proposed to be to be
plumbed in
you might be able to see the indicative
line of the um
the the Wastewater pipe uh Plumbing to a
package treatment plant in the uh in the
corner of the public beer garden there
and surface water is proposed to be
attenuated and just discharged at a
controlled rate to the uh
adjacent field ditch now there has been
a comprehensive
surface water drainage and flood risk
assessment submitted with
the uh the application as negotiated by
your officers and that has received the
approval subject to condition of the
lead local flood Authority at the County
Council
um
so that's approximately a third of the
site there you can see here the area
kept um
open for outdoor activities
um for use by by guests
and the camping Fields would be proposed
to the rear now um
our food and safety officers have
advised that there should be a maximum
of 25 camping pictures there
spaced uh no less than six meters apart
so to give you an idea
of the density we're looking at there
uh the next next life thank you
and just for completeness this is the
northern part of the site
to add I think on that slide so the next
slide please
so this is the proposed amenity building
it will be approximately uh four meters
in height to the to the ridge in facing
boarding
and the applicant says in their proposal
that it would have a stable character
sort of a whole stable character
appropriate to the countryside which
that it's appropriate
um if we could have the next slide
please the floor plan
so this is again as the amenity Spirit
building the floor plan so we have
wwc's and wash basins we have disabled
facilities here
showers also utility and Storage
and washing up basins which are
accessible externally
proposed
please
and just for completeness this is the uh
site layout in totality and to get it on
the slide I've had to leave it on the
side so apologies for that but hopefully
that shows it for you in totality there
[Applause]
on the next slide please so we're on to
some photographs so this is the existing
Pub and access
um it's a car parked in the visibility
space as well as bins that will be um
organized and conditioned so there's no
um no intrusion into the ear into
displays by way of condition
now there was a question of um
the pub open how long has it been closed
the applicant has responded to that
question that it has been closed since
June 2022 so it's about a year it's been
closed
not enough business able to be generated
to sustain it but hopefully that is the
aim of the campsite to help support the
pub and to have some ready-made
customers uh
so this is taken from Google Street
Scene images uh just looking the other
way down the road which gives you an
idea of the um
straightness of the road down towards
Crowfield there this is the cartilage of
the nearby listed building at New Hall
you might be able to see the footpath
sign here along the along the field
there
path continues on this side to the other
side of these these Conifer trees
and so this is a photograph taken from
the pub car park to so I'm showing the
rear of the existing pump building and
the existing beer garden thank you next
time and this is a photograph taken
within the field showing the existing um
static unit which
um yeah is no longer required for what
it was there for I believe someone was
living in living there and that was the
subject of a case which has been
investigated by your officers but um
yes the other The Proposal uh come on in
before you would regulate all that and
as I understand there's there's another
continual need for that to be occupied
by any individual and that would be
uh next slide please
no we don't have the final slide
apologies for that
um the final slide would have shown uh
the nearest amenities
attractions uh if I could just explain
that verbally to you apologies
visually
so the nearest public house would
obviously be the um
the rose which is on site the nearest
convenience shop uh I believe is at
cottam which is just down the road and I
believe that's got a coffee shop as well
other services and Facilities would be
at Needham market and Stow Market
approximately nine miles and 10 miles
away respectively and there are other
attractions um of the a1120 tourist
route
um as advertised on boards along that
um those big big brown advertisements
um all within 11 miles of the site um
uh now in terms of
um
bus connections I understand there's a a
bus service that operates from Tollgate
farm at the corner of Church Road which
is
from the site and that gives connections
to Ipswich and other places Monday to
Friday from 7 30 to
um
four in the afternoon every two hours
with a reduced service on Saturday and
unfortunately no service on Sunday so I
hope that gets an idea of
connectivity there
um
so nothing more to add really than
what's in the papers I think chairman
um as per officer's recommendation
um
your officer's recommendation is to
approve thank you
thank you do we have any questions from
Members Council headingham
I've got several of you in mind Alex
um so just wanted to check so there's no
pavement to walk to Crowfield The
Village
[Music]
just down the road where the nearest
shop was is that sort of walkable or
definitely a car trip
um it's about seven miles
um
with the the access road are cars going
to be allowed to drive down there and
park beside the static Caravans or
they've got to park in the car park at
the pub
uh I believe the intention is access to
uh unload and then you would come and
park your car at the car park
okay cool
um I think it was um when you when you
showed the bigger picture could you see
the stone and Barnes complex on I think
it was um slide or was it
so you know I'm I might be wrong like I
said I was just wondering if you could
still see that on the bigger picture
when you're showing where everything was
yeah right yes
actually now I can see it yeah cool
thank you and um and so it's the same
owners sorry like I said to keep
following you with questions so it's the
same owners it hasn't been um sold or
anything it's basically the same people
since it was
goes down to now it hasn't been you know
changed hands okay cool thanks yeah so
much
sorry so the pipes um are they going to
be over ground or underground the the
drain the you know the toilets and all
that yeah so I would be undergraded to
the um underground yes yes yes
okay
um councilman Elkin
um I think if I didn't miss here did you
say there was 17 parking spaces
um I'll just double check that for you
notes
[Applause]
21 21 designated I was just curious
because if there's a maximum of 25
camping pitches and five Statics and an
Open Pub
whether that would be sufficient parking
and if not does that have any
implications for the for the residents
of the the village and the houses nearby
you know obviously we'd not want people
to uh hike on the on the road
um I mean all I can say is that that
parking provision is in accordance with
Suffolk advisory parking standards and
yeah no objections from the highway
Authority
uh councilor Mathison I think human yeah
thank you yeah the um the the usual
problem
um in practice with with these kind of
questions
gonna be a question it's going to be a
question so the there's two conditions
um I'd like to hear a little bit more
detail about
um how they're going to be framed
um and that's the one that says approve
you speak to the public house
and and the other one is the one that
says
um restriction of use of the static
Caravans for holiday and tourism
purposes only
because enforcing those conditions has
been quite difficult in practice
right well in in terms of the linking it
to the pub
um I mean we'd have to talk about uh
what you know precise wording on that
but um yeah we felt that's reasonable
and that has been advised by the
economic development officer seen as
important there
yeah in terms of the the holiday use it
would be the uh the standard um
condition I believe it's 28 days from
memory
that's right yeah we
what somebody can
let go there for no more than a certain
amount of time and can't return again
within a certain amount of time as Alex
said normally 28 days so if you stayed
for a weekend you then couldn't come
back for another month and then we
require them to keep records of that so
yes difficult to enforce but something
that we do regularly use and have found
workable and again much as Bob mentioned
this morning has been typically used and
yeah that's it
a counselor War boys
thank you thank you chair uh
yeah Scouts I've touched on this it's
the um dispose of foul water I think
it's been raised by the parish councils
as well
um slide seven showed a treatment plant
which isn't connected up to anything
um I assume there'll be some discharge
into the drainage ditch
and and making some assumptions here
that this will be covered by building
rates and the necessary permissions will
be
obtained in order to enable the
discharge into the drainage ditch and
this will be regularly inspected but in
our conditions we've got a condition
about surface water drainage but
wouldn't it be appropriate to put a
condition in there and regards the
treatment plant as well
yes if you felt that is necessary
something we could consider to add yes
yes but I mean it would be
the discharge from the treatment plant
would be treated water so essentially
the discharge would be surface water you
know yeah in accordance with the whole
surface water drainage scheme but uh yes
if you felt a additional
thank you
uh thank you if there are no other
questions from Members I'd just like to
ask my own question
um
part the the root of the public right of
way
uh looks like it's just inside on the OS
map it looks like it's just in within
the site of the campsite and there
doesn't look to be an awful lot of
clearance between the corner of the
toilet block
and that fence and then the footpath
Looks To Me Maybe Maybe I'm Wrong it
looks like it then goes up between the
back of the static Vans and the fence
which might be a little bit of a
intrusion for those people using those
Caravans and I just wondered I I
understand public rights of way have got
their own rules and regulations but
um is there to be any rerouting of that
public footpath or is it already
rerouted unofficially
uh thank you chairman yes
um
now there are certain requirements that
um County Council public rights of the
way have uh required
um as part of their consultation
response
um so that that formalized route should
remain clear at the required
um required width
no they haven't raised objection to the
the layout proposed so
I'm presuming that that um that is
acceptable to them
um
and yeah the formalized route I mean the
only
the only location it would cross the
site would be
from
um from west to east if you will
um the uh
the pieces going
north to south
they would be outside of the outside of
the site boundary within the
existing field so I I believe there's a
uh I haven't walked along it yet myself
there is a uh it yes it it's fenced um
to the uh to the highway side adjacent
to the pub car park so um
yeah I mean there's there's nothing to
indicate that that
Roots good and there's not a proposal to
divert it that's how
it was more it was more than not the
next to the pub car park it was a bit
behind the Caravans I just thought it
might be a bit of a bit of a it's rather
close to those corners and the people
staying there might not like a load of
people walking along a public footpath
but I guess that's outside of our
control so there is a condition about
making sure it's it's still usable
um so as long as that is the case
whether they informally make it go a
slightly different route through their
site that I guess is up to them is is
that right
um yeah so if privacy was a an issue I
mean there are um conditions requiring
Landscaping if we can get some more
planting along that battery I think
that's the case anyway to screen it um
so maybe there's some privacy to be had
through that you know you have a
question at Council Davis
oh thank you chair yeah
um just like to look at the um the
toilet block
in a little more detail I noticed that
you had the disabled toilet which is
great is there a facility for
appropriate
um sharing of
people
received at
it wasn't a sort of wet room setup which
would allow for flexible use
and then also on the public toilet
building
is the provision for solar panel
generation to try and reduce the net
energy side of things
okay I'm just looking at the floor plan
here of the amenities building yes it
does say shower facilities in the
disabled part of that so um yes
presumption that would be provided there
there's no proposal for um
solar panels on the building
thank you
uh uh take it there's no further
questions from members uh so I will now
invite the public speakers to address
the committee
um there's no one from the parish
council uh no objector I believe there
is a supporter Mr Dave Gillingham
um if you would like to have your three
minutes with my high-tech timer thank
you
thank you very much
the Crowfield roads had been closed for
nearly eight years when the applicant
and his partner bought the pub in 2017
following 18 months of hard work they
reopened in April 2019 they'd managed to
establish a strong customer base
including many people from the
surrounding Villages and further afield
and the pub soon gained a reputation as
an excellent place to eat and to
socialize
I didn't tell any of you of the damage
calls to the hospitality industry by the
covert pandemic which struck them less
than a year after the pub had reopened
despite their best efforts the couple
were unable to recover their former
customer base and return the pub to a
sustainable level of business
as a consequence they took the sad
decision to close the Crowfield Rose in
January 22.
although a tenant subsequently leased
the pub from them for a number of months
they couldn't make a go of it either and
the pub has been now been closed since
June last year
however they're very very keen to see
this important local community Facility
reopen so they've been exploring ways
that the pub could return to
profitability using the existing assets
that they've got
this application is to convert one of
those assets a three acre field behind
the pub and diversify their business to
include a new Caravan and campsite
the intention is to create a welcoming
place for tourists with the Crowfield
Rose at its heart
the location only a very short distance
from the a1120 designated tourist route
fits perfectly with the new baber
mid-suffolk culture Heritage and visitor
economy strategy and of course the
government's National tourism recovery
plan
the national planning policy framework
also encourages the retention of local
services and Community facilities
including public houses and the new site
will certainly further that aim
despite being in a remote part of the
village the proposed site which is
already hidden by trees on three sides
will retain its current character by
careful use of landscaping planting and
screening and this will also enhance the
site's biodiversity
on a daily basis there'll be little more
traffic than on the days when the pub
was open already and the straight Roman
Road gives clear views in both
directions
the campsite will be accessible to a
wide range of Transport modes and will
provide special facilities for cyclists
and charging for electric vehicles
there'll be direct benefits to the local
economy too with businesses such as
Evergreen carriage in Crowfield being a
potential beneficiary of increased
business and there is also I have to say
a shop at the stone barns complex only
two miles away which sells pretty much
anything that that campers and Caravans
could need
to sum up this new campsite will
encourage tourism it'll boost the local
economy protect the character of the
site and most importantly this business
diversification will ensure a
sustainable future for the Crowfield
Rose public house as an important local
asset long into the future I hope that
the members of the planning committee
will support this application thank you
very much
thank you are there any questions from
members to the supporter cancer
thank you um how many years did you say
the the pub have been shut before
the pub had been shot for nearly eight
years when the applicant and his partner
bought it in 27
. and um is there a footpath or anything
to the stone and bars or is it if you've
got to go around by the roads I believe
the footpath goes across to up to the
a1120 it doesn't take you directly to
Stalin Barnes but it certainly cuts a
and um is there a football from from I
mean I mean
yeah no okay cool thank you
any further questions
uh thank you Mr Gilliam
um uh we have we can't
um but we do have the ward member so um
councilor hardingham uh if you'd like to
um speak about this application thank
you
yes the the main concern that's
[Music]
Caravan and the resident possible
residential or not residential status
that they they might acquire
um and I think the most important thing
in this apart from safeguarding the
future of the pub which obviously would
be a
thing for the community in The District
in general
um is to make sure that we don't repeat
a circumstance which has happened
elsewhere in the district and end up
with a
situation which can't be controlled into
the future
um and I would like to just emphasize
councilor mathison's point about the
means by which the council is able to
control the occupancy of the static
Caravans
in the ascertain whether those people
are temporary or whether they
are actually staying there for much
longer
and the other the other point to bear in
mind of course is that the the pub may
not stay in the same ownership and the
surrounding land may not stay in the
certain ownership so you wouldn't want
to see a
situation develop
thank you
thank you are there any questions from
members to The Ward member
uh could I ask my own question then do
you know how well used that public
footpath is
the one that's going to cut through this
campsite is is it is it a popular
walking route in the area
I think local people you
okay
um right there are uh if there are no
further questions
um I will now open this item Up For
Debate
oh did you
sorry
um is there any links between
um the you know because I can't remember
if there's some there's some sort of
Illusion in the papers but I don't know
if it was General sort of Gossip is
there any links between the owners of
this complex and the stone and Barnes
was it just here saying gossip oh I'm
not aware no no certainly the applicant
is not the owner of stone but I can say
that much yeah
okay um if there are no further
questions uh I will now open this item
Up For Debate um is there anyone who
would like to make start
councilor Mathison
yeah
the objectives are
are you know pursued here are are the
ones that we would want to support
um and you know the concern is as
councilor Harding members as the
expression I asked about
um is our ability to successfully keep
it in the uses that are set out here and
that that is the the primary worry about
it
um I think it has been pointed out that
there is a great deal of this sort of
um
tourism offer
um very nearby at Stoneham Barnes which
is a fair point
um but I don't think that the um
you know there's no sort of test or
policy which which um which talks about
that it's up to the the applicant to
make a go of it so to speak
um
and I I think you know on balance
probably
um I shall support it
um but I think I would want to try and
accommodate somehow what the chair has
talked about in terms of the the
the right of way that if there's all
that land there and and then it'll be
possible to
cite the the right of way a sufficient
number of meters away from the from the
static Caravans and so on
um
one way or another
you know office is good to have a bit
more of a think about that one whether
we give delegate authority to to um to
to tweak something
um with the applicant or whatever
um
something like that anyway
anything
say if not
um I mean I I just like to
I'm clearly the static Caravans are a
very different kind of fish from camping
does stone and Barnes actually offer
tent camping pictures or is it only
static Caravans or touring Caravans
and obviously we can only determine what
we've got before us which is
you know a campsite and temporary
accommodation in static Caravans
and although we want the conditions to
be worded as strongly as possible and
that we hope the enforcement team can
keep on top of them
um you know we have what we have is is
for a campsite uh and not for permanent
use so I'm not quite sure if we can
delve any further into that one but I do
understand the concerns of we don't want
it to become a permanent residence and I
do think that it's a it's an audible
attempt to keep the pub open to have a
campsite and and a personal re you know
if I personally was going camping I'd
far rather go somewhere with a small
site with a pub adjacent than stolen
Barnes
um but static Caravans are a different
thing so it it it's two things here
really isn't it it's a campsite for for
campers who are not likely to stay there
for a long period of time we might just
want a good beer in the pub and the
static Caravans which I think we are
more concerned about so if there is any
reassurance we can make sure that
condition is as strong as possible that
is only temporary accommodation uh
holiday accommodation thank you
um so yeah I think we have a couple of
different scenarios when it comes to
Caravans particularly that in some cases
they have year-long use and it's fairly
unrestricted but perhaps two weeks in
February you can't
live there
um that obviously opens itself up to
more problems because although
technically you should have another
arrest that you live at you can stay
there for
11 and a half months and that that can
be more problematic
um what I've just sort of um checking in
with Alex I'm sure you'll help me out if
I've got this wrong is that what we'd be
saying in this case is that you could
stay there for up to 28 days but not
anymore so you could go for a couple of
weeks no problem
um and then you couldn't stay there
again for another 28 days after the last
day that you leave so that should give
us enough security that it's quite short
you know we're not waiting for a year to
be up before we would have to consider
enforcement if somebody was staying
there longer than that we can request
those records and that we're making sure
they're getting enough churn which we
would like to hope would be what
supports the pub so I think that would
cover a lot of those issues and I think
give us a lot more security over what we
can and can't control
okay
councilor headingham
um with journalism clarification there
I'm happy to support um the officer or
nothing to go for um
approved
approval according to the As for the
offices
just um
I may be missing something obvious I
apologize to Gemma
the case but if the actual application
is for a change of use
I've just looked at the application
online and that just says tourism but we
put it as a caravan site now obviously
that there is the erection of a welfare
static caravan's office but are we are
we proposing are you advising members to
put a condition in limiting the number
of Caravans used for tourism
problem we've had where if you have if
you simply say you have to have if you
simply say you fight stationary of five
Caravans whether for residential or
tourist use you then have somebody
having six and saying not a material
change of use yes thank you you're
absolutely right we have had that
trouble in the past now I anticipated
that to be covered by
um restriction of the use of five
numbers static Caravans holiday and
tourist purposes Alex is nodding but we
might be very specific about that I
think we need to be clear that's what
members
it's very annoying when you a few years
later you find yourself in trouble over
that properties
um
Council
counselor thank you chair it
um yes I think overall I'd like to see
this be approved because I think
it's probably an important development
in terms of making the pub more viable
and
improving the economy in a rural area
um
but with regards to static Caravans and
there's a camping site where did touring
Caravans come into this are they
in a separate category together do they
fall into camping
as well
how the Delights of Caravans and camping
yes so there's lots of different issues
with with both so the static Caravans
obviously are more permanent and have
got that permanent hookup but as Alex
mentioned they've still got to comply
with the Caravan Act
whereas your static caravan itself is
sorry your
Towing Caravan touring Caravan is not
development it would be change of use of
the land for stationary Caravan we're
allowing stationing of five static
Caravans only and then the camping site
to my mind was a camping site not for
touring Caravans thanks Alex but so I
think from our side we're saying five
Statics and camping and that wouldn't
leave any middle ground for touring
it is as described and it's strictly
canvas and
the static Caravans yeah thank you I
think well yeah I would like to secondly
uh with with the condition about the the
foul water drainage
um plan I think is the best way to put
it is that possible to add that as a as
a condition they've about the foul water
yeah I don't think we've got a problem
with that if a proposer is happy
councilor Mathison
yeah yeah a couple of things about about
the conditions
um I I'd like to well first of all are
the hoes are in second uh
um
uh wanting to to accept my comments
about the um
the public right of way that the
officers new negotiate that to be
um
realistic usable
Etc I mean I think someone has
experienced with these matters as the
chair spots a potential problem then you
know it ought to be our job to to
actually make that problem not occur if
you see what I mean
um
sorry thank you yeah we were just
wondering if a public right-of-way
management condition might be the most
appropriate that would allow us to agree
a scheme of management of it on the site
obviously quite I think Beyond red lines
but to confirm they wouldn't allow it to
be blocked or otherwise
um you know prevent people from moving
through the both the site but also in
inside the site so some kind of
management
and is the chair happy to accept the
foul water drainage condition that was
suggested by the seconder
are you are you the chair sorry the
proposer yeah yeah sorry are you willing
to have accept the perhaps accepting
foul water drainage uh condition
Al Matheson right yeah the the other the
other things I wanted to say about the
conditions was was
um
first the the the
um I'd really like to hear a little bit
more about how the um we're going to
continue to link
the Public House ownership with the the
this the field
um and and then as as a much much
broader point that we we have made
progress
um in the last year or two in terms of
um when conditions are to be met and and
looking at this quite long long list in
this case actually
um there's quite a number there that
that want to be
um prior to commencement
and um so I I think if if we could make
sure that that we have a good close look
at that I mean I think that you know
that the last seven all look as if they
ought to be prior to commencement as
also
um at the highway ones I think it's
quite General that the highways access
would be prior to commencement and also
um
the biodiversity enhancement strategy
um you know I think to know that these
things were going to be worked out up
front
um it's reassuring really so I know that
I think you Jeremy recalls with that you
know there was quite a what about two
years ago 18 months ago
there was quite a revisiting of that the
whole business of the timing wasn't the
uh you know this is silk you know
obviously um you know subsequent to and
in concurrent with and so on and so
forth so I think if if we could get you
know a bit of work on on that list of
what 25 or something conditions to to
get them all happening at the right time
not not later than the right time if you
see what I mean thank you
yeah of course
um I think Alex was wondering about
prior to I think we're in a slightly
different situation here and it's a full
application for something fairly small
which is probably not going to come
forward in phases of five houses at a
time that then affect the timing of
those I would have thought the majority
were going to want before they do
anything uh there might be the odd thing
that's later on but you know there's not
a foundation level in the same way there
is with houses that we could all push
back to so I'm sure we can take that
away uh your other question about how it
would be tied to the pub Alex did you
have any initial starts on that
um
I think just um you know had some simple
wording that um
yeah the the campsite use will be linked
to the use of the pub or something
similar to that if that's enforceable
what we can talk about I think you
mentioned that the um that it was asked
per what economic development we're
recommending but I don't think we knew
what that was yes I haven't provided any
specific wording unfortunately
do we do we need to know what the what
the specifics are I mean you're right
that that condition that says the land
to if they're going to be removed and
land revert to that associated with a
public house if down the line that that
campsite is sold
up to another owner it's not going to be
in association with the public house is
it and there's nothing to stop the
current owner selling off the campsite
as a separate concern to the pub is
there
so is that is that condition which said
which is on the bottom of page 96 the
land reverted to that associated with
the public house is that actually
um feasible
yeah I think the the linking was about
the fact that this is expected to
support the public house that's the
reasoning behind it and therefore we
would foresee that being kept maintained
and run forward with the public house in
some way and I think that's what we
would like to secure by condition we've
seen to take the wording of that way but
I would suggest it's slightly different
to where we have houses
obviously they get sold off and that's a
capital investment this is a support to
the business
flow and productivity over the long term
would be where our position was on that
one but that's our expectation and to
take that away and do the wording to to
match but probably in discussion with
the applicant to make sure it does work
for their business planning as well
Council Lawrence
thank you chair
I just personally I don't think we
should get too concerned about the
ownership of the problem the ownership
of the company site
um it may split to different businesses
um the current owners haven't had income
from their investment for the last year
or so if they get planning permission
for this they might use it as an
opportunity to increase the asset value
and sell it and leave it to somebody
else to actually implement but that's
not our concern as a planning committee
thank you
uh is there so are we have we now got a
a proposal
um with any extra conditions that you
need to just clarify before we go to the
vote uh yeah thank you I can do so we've
got the recommendation on pages 96 to 97
with additional conditions for foul
water treatment and the public
right-of-way management I hope that's
everything that members were after
are they proposal and seconder happy
with that um
that that what's just been said by the
planning manager
um so we will now go to the vote if I
can ask the governance officer to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you members chair that's seven
votes for
um as councilor Harding is not voting as
a board member that's therefore
unanimous that's Carrie thank you thank
you
um so uh we will now move to the next
application unless anyone as a burning
desire be nice to get the next one out
of the way before we have another break
uh councilor hardingham needs to return
to his seat
um and do we have the planning officer
ready
so we'll just take a few minutes just
for people to get to their seats
um I think I think we're all ready to go
now uh on our next case which is land uh
on the Southeast side of Church Road
Scotland uh and I'll invite the case
officer Jasmine wired to introduce the
application thank you
thank you chair and good morning members
um so I'm presenting the reserve matters
for consideration today which include
appearance Landscaping layout and scale
for the erection of 18 dwellings
um a car park for the primary school and
Cemetery extension
so members are reminded that this
presentation does not seek to replace
the content within the committee report
and should be viewed in conjunction with
the detailed information within that
report
so here is the site in its wider context
as you can see it joins existing
residential development to the Northwest
and Southwest so along here and along
here and you've got some slightly more
sporadic development here and the blore
homes
residential estate up here
um so
also I think this came up in briefing
there's a pump house just here which is
outside of the um the red line but is uh
angling Waters
ET there is agricultural land to the
east and south of the site and Freeman
Community primary school is opposite
um the site just here and then you've
got the the church kind of next to it as
well and the site is accessed via Church
Road which is also known as the a1120
so in terms of the constraints on the
site the site shown by the hatched area
and so you've got the built up area
boundary for stopping which is shown by
that Brown Line
uh then you've got a public driveway
which runs along here and then down
side of the site and then you've got the
grade two listed Holy Trinity Church
which is the nearest Lister building
just here
so some site photos now the next three
slides show photos which are taken from
around the site um specifically along
Church Road and the public right-of-way
and the site's location is shown in all
the photos by the yellow star
so both photos one and two are taken
along Church Road with the site shown on
the right hand side which is opposite
the church and the primary school which
is just here so you've got the lay-by at
the primary school down here and then
the church just here
um a crossing point is to be installed
along here
um which was secured under the outline
permission
which will then connect the car park to
the school and church
so both photos three and four are now
looking kind of southwards towards and
into the site so in photo three this is
the existing angular Pump House
with the site just over here to the
right then photo 4 is taken looking into
the site and as you can see it's it's
just kind of grasped agricultural land
at present and is fenced off
so moving on to photos five and six is
the final two photos and these have been
taken along the public right-of-way so
the public RightWay runs along here as
you can see it's unobstructed and then
the site is just here and this is
basically where the sun spacings would
go in this corner and then this is
looking
um
further into the site from the public
right away so it's taken from up here
looking this direction and this is the
other house on the other side which is
the Bungalow
um just in the distance there it's not
particularly clear but that is the other
nearest dwelling compared to the one
that's just behind this uh
so in terms of the planning history on
the site outline planning permission
which included the access points that's
not a consideration today was granted in
um under 1884 16.
um a range of conditions were imposed on
the outline which applied to these
reserved matters which I've summarized
in the community report and also
hopefully you've all been sent a copy of
the outline planning permission as well
and so these conditions don't need
repeating Within These reserved matters
but obviously some of them are linked
into it
um so in terms of the section 106 that
was signed under the outline permission
um we've got six affordable dwellings
secured and then a car parked to the
frontage of the site which I'll show you
on the site plan in a minute which is
for the staff of the church and primary
school this did also include the
specification management and maintenance
information to be submitted as well and
agreed and however the outline planning
permission although it's in the
development description does not secure
the delivery of the cemetery extension
there's no provision for the transfer to
the parish council or any other thing
that you you typically see in the
outline
so in terms of verbal updates since the
issue issue table papers start from
Parish counselor provided additional
comments which are summarized on screen
and whilst there is no statutory and
it's not necessarily typical that we
would consult the Parish Council on any
discharge of conditions application we
know the local feeling around
construction traffic and a note can be
left on the case File so when we do have
the discharge conditions application
informal construction management plan
and we will consult the Parish Council
on it
um we do note that the parishes
obviously disappointed a failure to
deliver the cemetery extension and this
is this is noted
um however it's it's addressed within
the report and this presentation
um
so in terms of the the neighborhood plan
uh stockland's labor plans adopted in
2019 uh and allocated the site under
policy snp4 which is uh shown on the
screen now whilst other policies within
the neighborhood plan are also relevant
this is the policy that specifically
deals with how the development on the
site is expected to be brought forward
the proposed Reserve matters are
considered to comply with this policy
some aspects so specifically in terms of
the uh like locally distinctive
materials just here that's actually
reserved by condition and can be
appropriately dealt through
um dealt with through discharge and
conditions application
so moving on in terms of the site layout
plan there's quite a lot to cover here
so uh starting with the housing mix
um it's quite varied and includes the
six affordable units
these are plots one to six on the plan
there is a slight change or a proposed
data variation has been submitted to
change the affordable housing mix not
the 10 years but the mix so I think one
of the units is to be changed into a
three-bedroom house
and but that has been agreed with our
strategic housing team and is including
the recommendations so it's a separate
application and it's been submitted just
to vary that affordable housing mix so
this is what he's presented now
um so we've then got two one-bedroom
Bungalows two two bedroom two-story
houses five three bedroom Bungalows five
three bedroom two-story houses one four
bedroom Bungalow and three four bedroom
two-story houses across the site so
there is quite a mix
and the car park for the staff of the
church and primary school is to the
frontage so it's this area here and then
you can possibly see there's a small
Crossing Point here which is what was
secured on the outline and I showed you
on the site photos earlier
and then you've got the uh the cemetery
extension is is down here this would be
um only for the scattering of Ashes
because of groundwater pollution and has
been discussed with the environment
agency so if this was to come forward
and be transferred to the parish council
which is basically all it could be used
for
um this would be something that it would
have to kind of remain grassed area but
there would be an access point running
along here and a small car park as well
here
and I will show you in a later slide
there is also a Footbridge that's
conditioned to be provided to wrap
around into the existing Cemetery which
is over just outside here
um all of the dwellings will be served
by air source heat pumps and would have
secure covered cycle storage
um adequate space is provided on site
for bin storage and presentation areas
which provided for each dwelling off of
the highway
the proposed site now is spread out over
the so you've got the main Access Road
here and then you've got three sort of
main share drives you've got one long
hair you've got one here and then one up
here and then there's a parking Court
just here but it is to the frontage of
the dwellings it's very well overlooked
um in terms of connectivity there's then
the foot way that runs alongside the
spine Road and also there would be a
connection through into the public right
of way just here between the suds basins
um sudden landscape and are Incorporated
throughout the scheme which we discussed
and shown in the later slide
and then you've got the play Space which
is located centrally within scheme just
here this place to base is well
overlooked by the dwellings on the
opposite side of the road with Windows
serving plots two three and four
directly looking out over it and you've
then also got the parking areas serving
plots two to six and plot 16 which are
obviously and adjacent to that play area
and all
is very essentially centrally located
within the site
so in terms of elevations the following
slides show a selection of house types
it doesn't show all of them but they
were included in the pack that opening
members have seen
so I'll just give you a selection of
them so here we have a pair of
semi-detached two-story three-bedroom
dwellings
then we have a Terrace of Bungalows and
two-story dwellings the Bungalows are
one bedroom and the two-story houses are
two bedrooms
then you've got
um detached two-story dwellings so the
top is a four bedroom dwelling and the
bottom is a three bedroom dwelling
and then we've got final two examples
which are both Bungalows so both of
which would have three bedrooms
material details as I mentioned earlier
are reserved by condition and a
discharging conditions application is
currently under consideration this is in
consultation with our heritage team
noting that obviously you've got the
grade two listed Church opposite the
site
oh
okay then go
um there are numerous garages around the
site as well all of which would conform
to soft County council's Highway
standards for parking there are a
mixture of single and double Bay garages
so that's just to give you an idea as
well
so moving on to the Landscaping there
are a range of trees hedgerows and grass
areas located around the site as you can
see so this is the top half the site the
next slide will show you the kind of
bottom half just so it's zoomed in a
little bit more and so this is the car
parked area
and you've got the play Space there and
the suds over here Suds and swales have
been designed to meet Southern County
Council floods and Waters and standards
and place Services Landscaping have
reviewed all of the Landscaping details
and are happy with the proposed species
which is a mix and is native
there would also be a mixture of post
and rail fencing and close boarded
fencing around the site and all the
close boarded fencing is located between
plots and is kept to an absolute minimum
and Hedgehog highways are also proposed
alongside other biodiversity enhancement
measures across the site
um so in terms of the kind of Southern
half of the site now and this is where
the proposed symmetry extension is so as
you can see this area would have to be
laid out as grass area but this is the
the kind of keep it that hasn't been
secured and then you've got this
Footbridge which is secured under
condition which then links into the
existing Cemetery
um the specified play Space is to be um
to be delivered is of a Timber
construction and uh is this
um kind of structure shown just here so
that would be located
uh
so in terms of the recommendation uh
it's therefore to approve the reserve
matters subject to the conditions within
the committee report and following the
data variation being assigned to vary
the affordable housing mix
listening uh thank you
um uh before I ask members for questions
can you just um clarify this bit about
the one of the affordable houses is
changing to a three bed house because if
we've got plans in front of us that
we're approving and then they're going
to change the house is that no so the
plans that have currently been submitted
is what we would be approving
um the deed of variation that's been
submitted is to basically support what's
been shown to members today
does that make sense my other question
is the the cemetery that is not within
the reserve matters
has been shown to have a bit of car
parking and some grass and some trees
is that is that what is actually going
to happen or is there no obligation for
the developer to do anything with that
bit of land other than offer it to the
parish council so the the Landscaping
can
be composed um and this is including the
committee report would secure basically
all of the landscaping that's shown on
site
um so it would have to be grasped
um obviously in terms of the land
transfer and its actual end use
that we have no control over because
that ought to have been on the outline
under the kind of section 106 obligation
um I believe and the agent's here so he
might be able to provide some further
clarification on this but I believe
landex have spoken to the parish council
to discuss uh the situation I think they
would be happy to construct it uh it
just wouldn't be at their cost
and obviously they'd have to transfer
the land over and again we have no
control at the developers cost or at the
parish council
so so if the parish council wants the
developer to to to do the landscaping
and surfacing the car park they would
have to pay them so the Landscaping will
be covered by the condition so that will
be out of the parish council's
um I suppose funding and control uh the
access road and the car park are the
matters of the parish council would have
to fund and obviously they would then
need to discuss the land transfer as
well and how that's managed
um because that that hasn't been covered
under the outline so so in the absence
of any further negotiation the bit that
is shown as a car park on our plan would
actually just be grasped
uh yes basically I mean the problem is
with any planning permission unless you
specify via conditional section 106
obligation uh there is no obligation for
a developer to complete a development so
it's difficult to say what would happen
to that specific area
um but I suspect it might be possible to
potentially condition maybe some
additional Landscaping details
um
is quite a tricky one because the rest
the rest of the Landscaping surrounding
that area will have to be done
so we might need to
have some thought
on that and how that's left
are there any further questions from
Council of War boys I think you've
thank you chair yeah two questions
um one uh the car parking for the
primary school and church staff how
would that be
designated that there is a high school
down the road and parking is an issue
there
from from memory
um so how would that be sort of
so there is actually a management
um and maintenance plan that's included
in the section 106 that needs to be
agreed I believe that as part of that
there is um a gate and a keypad to that
gate which would obviously receive
strict its use to the intense users
because I appreciate obviously the
Village Hall does get quite congested as
does the the crown and obviously still
Auckland high school like you say is
just up the road and so I believe that
that is covered under the section 106
agreement but I can probably find the
specific wording for you if that's
helpful as well
the second was um on the the the
buildings the proposed buildings the the
finishes was I right in when you said
that the Heritage officer was going to
advise on the the finish and
and the range because they're very
uniform the way
yes so um Heritage team have been
consulted on this application so in
terms of how the elevations look they
raise an objection because they don't
believe there's any harm to the list of
building
um in terms of the specific material
details and how that's that's kind of
um laid out they are currently being
considered by our heritage team under a
separate discharger conditions
application
thank you
yeah they I'm kind of taking a step back
from the the what's just been said about
the cemetery and so on I mean what's
worrying me I mean is that the did the
original outline decision by the
committee
did they believe that they were going to
get the cemetery extension and the car
park as part of the of the planning
balance at outline stage because
um if they're not getting it then you
know that really their decision does
look
difficult
um and um and then tied up with that I
didn't quite really understand what
paragraph 2.7 was telling me about um
Deeds of variation to remove obligations
etc etc etc
um it's quite what's going on on there
um
so taking your first point
I wasn't the original case officer for
the applications I can't specifically
comment on what happened within
committee what I do know is that the
committee report didn't say in the
recommendation that there would be a
cemetery extension secured
um via planning obligation or condition
so I don't know the specifics of of what
happened
um with it but I think the the key point
is we are where we are now
um and we can't we can't condition that
at this point or request an obligation
um the kind of time for that has passed
um in terms of 2.7
um this is where it gets a little bit
confusing so we've got two data
variations that are currently submitted
to us one of which seeks to remove the
car park obligation to the front so the
one that's for the staff of the primary
school and the church and this is not
this has not been agreed to by us
um and will not be agreed to by us
either and because that that obligation
still serves a useful purpose and which
has been confirmed by the primary school
and the church
um in terms of the affordable housing
mix in order to address the change in
the site plan that you've seen today
that's a separate obligation
um which seeks to change that mix so
members can endorse what has been
proposed and then in front of you today
um but that's that's kind of the
difference between so there are two data
variations the one we really need to be
concerned of is the one that's reflected
in the recommendation which is just to
change
yeah thank you I mean I'm not too
worried about being
sorry the affordable housing mix one but
the the
um you know we're seeking to take away
some of the the value to the community
of what's been delivered here and I mean
and in terms of the the first point that
I made I mean really I'm
you know I'm perhaps a legal officer can
can advise that the um
you know is is it really a valid
decision at the outline stage if if it
if it was taken in a mistaken belief
that they were going to get something
that they're not going to get
well if the was made it was a long while
ago I'm afraid long past any Prospect of
a legal challenge
so it as it is it stands
I just asked so the
there's been a request to change the
requirement for the car park at the
front next to the highway
so clearly that goes to to the council
what is their process for
um negotiating or otherwise with that
suggestion of a deed of variation
um so Adida variation they are a
slightly strange form of application
because they're not really a planning
application or they're not a planning
application rather
um they don't actually have to be
accepted by us as even valid within I
believe
years
so we are I think still just within it
aren't we still just with it
it's more five years
like planning inspector so yeah so I
suppose where we are with it now is that
we still believe when you assess the
data variation it is basically do we
believe that that planning obligation
still holds a use purpose the answer to
that is yes and so our position is that
we would not be accepting that data
variation the applicant has the right to
appeal that is that what you say yes
when it's a valid
yeah the week from what Jasmine's saying
we would hope to defend and be
disappointed if we didn't persuade a
planning inspector who still had a good
planning purpose
you can take it from that that the
application that we're determining today
includes the provision of that car park
because the council are saying no to
that suggested change of variation or
whatever it's called and we are looking
at the development as it is on the plan
including the provision of that car park
yes exactly that and I think probably
useful to note that any planning
obligation Ever After the five years any
is you know at the applicants
prerogative to submit an application for
us to consider doesn't necessarily mean
we would accept it but it is something
that can happen on on all planning
applications but this one do just for
full transparency we are not accepting
it
um Council Davis
ah thank you chair
you said quite a bit about pedestrian
access and vehicle access to the site
are there any observations or provision
made for recycling I'm not familiar with
the area but here there's a high school
new bikes
linkage to other transport means would
be good so the agent might be able to
provide a little bit more information on
this but in terms of these submitted
details the proposed uh Footwear
alongside the the internal access road
is two meters wide
so I believe it could be used for
cyclists but obviously that would be
down to Suffolk County Council because
the other thing is at present the
internal estate Road has not been the
detail provided is not to an adoptable
standard it's the agents and the
applicant's intention to amend that
information so it is brought up to an
adoptable standard
um and obviously we can we can have
further discussions about the kind of
cycling provision
um but I suppose it's a side to that and
each dwelling is provided with secure
cycle story
are there any further questions from
Members Council of War Boys you've got
another question
so I should have perhaps added this
um
I I think it's a slide um 23 uh it
mentions as access to the agricultural
Fields behind the development
which I I assumes at that point
um
by the side of the extent
possible extension to the cemetery
so there'll be agricultural vehicles
so there probably is a a kind of right
of access for agricultural vehicles to
access that rear area that's retained as
agricultural land and that's outside of
the application site that's probably why
that's there but again it might be worth
um asking the agent that question
thank you
um the
um hardingham
yeah I think I saw somewhere in the
papers a mention of synthetic grass
being used somewhere on the site
and I just wanted to query it up
bear with me one second because uh
yes so the synthetic grass is around the
play Space it's not around any any kind
of wider part of the site and it is
solely uh so synthetic since the
synthetic grass with Timber edging uh by
Play-Doh who were the ones that provide
the the play Space they're the
manufacturer of the play Space
um and it is solely around
um the kind of internal part around that
play Space so I don't know if we can get
the slides back up just so I can show
you
so the synthetic grass would solely
surround in this kind of inner circle
here
everything else around it
and within the wide site is is all real
um
is that scene is the best option for
play areas
nowadays I mean I'm familiar with using
wood chip which is obviously entirely
biodegradable and easily replaced as
well I'm sure that's something we kids
we can pick up via condition if that's
that's not to members kind of preference
um I don't think there's there's any
sort of play Space guidance specifically
on that and it's just what's been
proposed
uh councilor Elkin
an um artificial grass is that it gets
absolutely scolding hot in the summer
which if you have small children it's
it's not brilliant um so just another
thought on that um but my question was
um about the the foul water drainage
whether it was going to be connected or
not I'm sorry if I misunderstood
something but it seemed to mention it
was at one place and not in another so
yes so foul water drainage
um it's a bit of a it's a bit of strange
one because it is covered by building
regulations anyway
um but in terms of the the foul water
drainage we've spoken to anglian water
and they originally said that that I
think they've misinterpreted the plans
basically that it wasn't they weren't
having any connection to them
um that's incorrect the applicant does
intend to connect into Anglo motor
sewers it's not going to be any sort of
private connection and that is outside
of the remit of of kind of
um planning in terms of how that
connection is made
but in terms of I believe members voted
on
the kind of foul water considerations
and capacity um
a few months back and so angling water
have confirmed that they there is not
capacity at Stone Market recycling
center however they have a statutory
Duty which is completely outside of our
remit to ensure that there is capacity
made and obviously whether they make
that capacity or not is is not something
we can really comment on
oh thank you
um Can someone raised the the issue of
the pay the The Pedestrian access the I
know the access Arrangement is not part
of this application because that was
part of the previous application
um but there appears to be a bit of
pavement on the front side of the
development but there's no pavement
existing on that stretch of road so it
looks like the bit of pavement you were
talking about being two meters right why
Goes To Where The Pedestrian Crossing is
on on one side but what happens to it on
the other side it goes nowhere I presume
boat worthy development is the other
side of the access road also has a gray
bit of on the plan which looks like
pavement that just then stops and goes
into the verge
is to just stop it there
um obviously I don't think they want to
necessarily encourage people to cross
here when there is a crossing point here
um but that does then link into the
lay-boy
um
if there are no further questions
um I will open this up to the public
speakers
we've got nothing further from the
parish Castle
we have an objector Mr Keith Willem if
you'd like to have your three minutes
is this gear
thank you very much Chad uh thank you
for this opportunity to speak
um I was chair of the parish council
when the development of this site was
first put forward under pre-planning
exhibition of proposals was held in the
Village Hall
there was a promise of a fully laid out
extension to the cemetery next door to
the plot with a path leading to the
existing area for the burial of ashes
and the Memorial Wall also a promise of
the car park and the vehicular access
The Village needed to extend the
cemetery in the area offered was ideal
the car park too
as they were currently only four spaces
for the cemetery users and that's on the
wide
wide verge of the 1120 which has been
concreted over
the car part for use by School staff and
church attendees fully laid out with a
promise from the landowner of ongoing
management and maintenance was also
promised
members of the porch family reside in
the village
and their company proposed the
development and the outline application
was submitted on their behalf they are a
well-respected building firm
only two significant concerns remained
at that time one was keeping parents
from using areas within the development
for dropping off children
and the other was the dangers of
crossing the a1120
so I spoke at the development control
committee way back six years ago or
thereabouts when the outline application
was debated I asked members to specify
details of the cemetery extension and
car park by way of conditions but both
were left and subsequently have been
called causes for concern the committee
did today has an opportunity to
condition both the cemetery and
extension and the car park in some
detail we need to ensure that the
applicant provides the cemetery
extension with suitable boundary
treatment and Landscaping with the car
park as originally offered together with
an access from the estate Road and the
car park were used by the school staff
and church attendees together with the
long-term management and maintenance
plan
although landex and their agent who
happens to be sitting alongside me
nearly have not really engaged with the
community a virtual meeting did take
place on the 26th of January 23 arranged
by the planning officer
a representative of landex and the agent
attended that meeting as did I as the
then District councilor
details of the cemetery extension its
boundary treatment Landscaping car park
and access were discussed in detail and
agreed and there was discussion about
the transfer of land
I came away from that meeting confident
that construction of the car park and
access and provision of a boundary hedge
or fence would be provided by the
developer I believe that my fellow
District councilor and Vincent pierce
the planning officer also believed that
blandex would provide these words were
like that sorted then isn't it
um now I didn't seek reelection as a
district council so I now speak as a
resident of the of the village is a is
is up so if you could just um finish I
will finish up quickly
um
yeah so in summary I'm seeking clear
conditions in respect of the cemetery
extension its vehicular access its car
park and The Pedestrian path and
transfer of the land by the foot and it
will be by the Footbridge which has
already been conditioned I'm seeking
clear conditions to ensure the car park
for school staff and church attendees is
provided managed and maintained and
finally
I clearly set out construction
management plan which takes account of
traffic on the a1120 including Vehicles
turning in and out of the Village Hall
car park and Churchill age times of the
secondary school primary school and
preschool a safe temporary access to the
site to be agreed and provided urgently
because of present access is not safe
that fences moved if a big vehicle comes
through
um thank you and also restrictions
placed on the use of Machinery when
burials are taking place
thank you
um
yeah
the the objector has mentioned
conditioning
um is that is that actually uh feasible
I don't believe it is and I think I'd
probably turn to uh
do we have any questions of the objector
no um to to stay where you are in case
there are further questions about the
parish
um so I I would now like we don't have a
supporter but we do have the agent Mr
Leslie short
um if you would like to
um begin your speech now I think
thank you chair
good morning members I'm Leslie short
I'm agent to the applicants
planning permission exists an outline
for the development of 18 dwellings on
this site
so we're here today to consider the
details of those dwellings and the
development scheme in which they're
proposed
you may be interested to know that to
get to this point we've had three
different planning case offices
two different Heritage officers all with
countless exchanges between us together
with a number of meetings not just one
with members of the parish council
proposals before you today have taken 11
months or have been 11 months in the
making which is only slightly less than
it will take to build these houses
we have genuinely enjoyed working with
starplan Parish Council and wish to
continue to do so as this development
progresses indeed we have already
produced the draft construction
management plan and want to ensure that
this works for everyone
the developer landex limited also the
applicant today
is well known to this Council and to its
partner Authority baber Council as
you've acquired 17 of its affordable
dwellings in Wool pit 12 in great
wolding field and eight at Raiden
the company has also developed a number
of high quality smaller scale
developments in the area it's Donna
massable Boxford hindlesham landex are
also present in Scotland having recently
completed development of 10 homes in
nearby Crown Meadow
landex are a local company with an
accent on the delivery of quality
construction and the delivery of new
homes that people want
and I trust you can agree that this is
represented in the submission
the details before you are entirely
considered consistent with policy and as
presented in your office's very
comprehensive report and I trust you can
accept her recommendations I'll use my
elastic three minutes to say to you I'm
more than happy to discuss the section
106 agreement the section 106 variation
applications because there's a very long
story behind them to get where we are
today thank you
okay
um
do we have any questions of Mr short
counts
thank you chair yeah yeah yes
um
the access to the agricultural land
behind the development and it's well as
it says it's secured by Foster gate and
that would necessarily involve sort of
agricultural Vehicles passive backers
and forwards uh could you could you
expand on that and just clarify the
situation please
I don't know if it's possible to go back
to a site layout plan probably the
second Landscaping drawing would help
the one to the south of that
if you look at that plan and see the
curved Access Road there first of all
landex bought from the porch Building
Company this site there's an obligation
to provide continued access to the land
to the rear unfortunately this plan
doesn't show it but to the south of
maybe shout on one of the um General
layout plans but that access leads to
the rest of an enclosed field there are
hedge line boundaries on all three other
sides and therefore the only access I
think and obligated to earn the sale
contract is to provide an access to
porch to the land of the rail
and it's it's simply closed off by a
five bar gate
so so there will be agriculture yes they
will then prices but it's arable land so
the actual frequency of agricultural
Vehicles isn't going to be great
any further questions of Mr short
Art Council dating
I'm trying to ask the the pointed
question
um when it comes to the financing of the
sanitary car park what's your current
position
um our current position is and this was
in a detailed conversation with Stuart
Parish Council one of three meetings
that we've had with them
um when landex bought this land you buy
it with an extant planning permission
the planning permission document is the
Bible as far as advising on value
it's important to say that section 106
agreement attached to that Planning
Commission contains probably the most
detailed specification I've ever seen in
relation to a car park and its future
maintenance and management for the car
park at the front of the site
so absolutely clear on that it's costed
into landex appraisal from day one
the section 106 agreement also provided
for that car park obligation to be
discharged if certain things happen
the car park for the cemetery and the
cemetery extension there is nothing in
either the planning consent or the
section 106 agreement in relation to the
provision of that Cemetery however we
recognize that that is part and parcel
of the application
but the cost of that the provision of
that access road the 70 parking spaces
is not
it's not an obligation the developer
landex in the meeting with the staff and
parent Parish Council said that they
would integrate the construction of the
access road together with the car
parking spaces into the development
program because as you can see the
cemetery extensions located at the rear
part of the site and they would do it at
Cost not at the parish council's cost at
cost and that offer was made to the
Stockland Parish Council in that
an offer that landex still stand by
any further questions to Mr short
okay I I believe we have some statements
from the board members which I will read
out and we have two Ward members for
still Upland
councilor eberne and councilman Pearson
um so
um first of all I've got a a message
from councilor e Byrne for this
application which I will read out this
application has been a long process not
helped by the almost complete lack of
consultation with the developer during
the duration duration of the reserve
matters application there has been no
public consultation no proactive
discussion with the parish council and
no other productivity on the developers
part despite the efforts of the planning
offices involved
the site is in the neighborhood plan
policy snp4 for 18 homes a community car
park and a symmetry extension site there
are three outstanding issues arising
from this application the cemetery
extension the community car park and the
construction management plan when
outline permission
161884 was granted despite the title of
the application including the words
extension to cemetery no condition was
applied to ensure a cemetery extension
was properly laid out now reserved
matters we have land set aside for a
much needed Cemetery extension but only
the land no hard landscaping for parking
for Access or for official needs of the
time of an inter internment all that is
due to be provided is a footpath link to
the existing cemetery on the adjacent
land
the parish council is responsible for
the cemetery and has been working for
years to gain this extension and as such
this lack of infrastructure for it is
extremely disappointing their comments
on page 104 of the papers note this we
ask that the committee provides some
conditions on this application to
correct the submission regarding
infrastructure for the cemetery
extension
secondly there has been much debate
about the community car park directly
alongside Church Road there is a
definite need for more parking to serve
the community but particularly the
primary school and the church
fortunately despite the developers
efforts to have this excluded from the
application via variation to the section
dc2203911 the community car park has
been agreed we would like confirmation
that this variation to the section 106
is refused and that the committee gets
assurance that this car park is being
delivered and that that it will be
maintained by the developer as per page
109 of the papers
the third an outstanding point is the
construction management plan
currently the developers are using the
access to the north west of the site
often blocking or impeding the public
footpath and there are bright lights
across the site please can I ask the
committee to ensure that the footpath
remain clear at all times that lighting
is kept to an absolute minimum and the
operating times are also clearly stated
given the history and Scotland of
developers not sticking to their
construction management plans we would
ask that the parish council has site of
this plan before it is agreed and it
includes clear instructions on
deliveries keeping the footpath clear
lighting and operating hours to conclude
this site has been expected to deliver
to be delivered but must include the
cemetery extension fully laid out for
use by the community and the car park
and the ongoing maintenance of it and
the clear construction management plan
that the parish council can check
particularly detailing access to the
footpaths thank you for your
consideration uh councilor Rachel e
Byrne we also have a message from
councilor Janet Pearson
um and I'll just read that one out as
well although not involved in matters of
this application in the earlier stages I
am aware of the outstanding issues
described by councilor e Byrne
a cemetery extension is much needed for
this community but neither land alone
nor a footpath linked to the existing
Cemetery are sufficient the land to be
capable of proper use as a cemetery must
have hard landscaping for parking and
official needs I therefore reiterate
councilor e Burns request that the
committee provides some conditions on
this application to correct the previous
Omission regarding infrastructure for
the cemetery extension
with regards to the community car park
alongside Church Road there is a need
for more parking space to serve the
growing Community I also request
therefore that confirmation is obtained
that the variation to the section 106 to
exclude the community car park is
refused and that the committee receives
assurance that the car park is being
delivered and that it will be maintained
by the developer as per page 109 of the
papers
finally a construction management plan
is vital footpaths must be kept clear
and light pollution kept to a minimum
possible operating times must be clearly
defined it is very important that the
parish council has cited this plan
before it is agreed and that it includes
clear instructions on keeping the
footpath clear lighting and deliveries
and operating hours thank you for
considering these points Janet Pearson
so um we don't we don't have the um
either of the ward members here today
um are there any questions relating to
either of their
um comments
no okay
so
um we now need to open this item Up For
Debate councilor Mathison
the difficulty is you mustn't discuss
this case outside whilst you're on your
comfort break so I have to trust you all
see seeing as you are so nicely
councilor Mathison we'll have a five
minute Comfort Break
um but please you must not discuss this
application outside
um of the public forum of the council
chamber
case
um
we uh we now need to open this up for
debate so
um who would like to go first
councilor having them I can if you like
I think there's obviously a bit of
discrepancy here between what the parish
council say how they feel they've been
treated
and what the developer how he says he's
dumb I think it's unfair to to judge
them on some obviously
say mishap but anyway overlooking shall
we say of how the last one was was
dealt with and um
and I like completely understand that if
um when this um the land was bought by
the the developer now you know they they
hadn't you know that they wasn't
mentioned and so obviously in their
pricing schemes it wasn't you know like
I say built into the deal
and um which I think is obviously harsh
if we then then say we've got to do this
to whatever standard and and lump it at
their door so I think it is a tricky one
and um so yeah I'm decided undecided at
the moment and I'm I'm just going to
listen to what everyone else has to say
uh anyone else like to say anything
counselor Madison yeah I I I yeah I
agree with that I find it extremely
difficult to to actually
see you know a decision out of this
um you know there is a very clear
difference and I did ask the question at
the outset as to the
um
you know I wasn't on the committee I
don't think on that day which was quite
a long time ago
um now someone said
um
but you know members sat there and and
agreed to the principal
and it seems as if they they believe
they were going to get these Community
benefits
half of which
they're not
now apparently going to get and you know
I I just don't I don't feel comfortable
agreeing to that
um you know agreeing to this Reserve
matters on the basis it doesn't fit as
if we're putting it on on firm and
proper ground of the of the original
outline it just doesn't just doesn't
seem right
uh thank you I think the the problem
here and we can't we can't go back in
history and change that outline and and
if we however many much
what maybe what should have happened
that hasn't happened and we can't change
that so we have to determine this
application as it is uh and I agree I
think maybe it's miscommunication maybe
there have been some other mistakes that
have been made in the past but
unfortunately we can't change that
and I I agree it's very difficult
because if we don't
whatever we decide today that
um Cemetery extension is not going to be
completed even if another Reserve
matters comes through and given that the
the applicant and the agents are already
trying to dispute the front car park
doesn't hold me in in great confidence
um that should we refuse this they're
going to come back with something more
generous
um but anyway we are where we are and we
can't go back and change that section
106 agreement
so we have to determine what we've got
in front of us so councilor Davis did I
see you waving your hand about
uh thank you chair yes I was uh doing
the gesticulation uh I'd just like to
pass the observation that the housing
mix here is one that seems to offer some
flexibility to the community which must
be welcome
clearly keeping that front car park
has OG specified as a fundamental
importance
if there was some way of
through
more Equitable resolution about the
cemetery that we've moved
very welcome
anyone else got anything to say
boys
uh yeah I I think I just need
a little bit of clarification
um I think
I'd like to follow
councilor Davis's comments I think it in
a lot of respects this is quite an
honorable development it's uh Pepper Pot
in the affordable housing there's a
range of styles Bungalows which is
probably sort of very
appropriate for for the Village
um
my understanding of this I I look at
just looking at the drawings of the
landscape the front car park is
agreed
that there is some indication of car
parking and a bridge to the
um Cemetery
but it's the actual Landscaping of the
plot of land that would
it could be a
Cemetery extension is in question I
think the the Footbridge is
determined that's going to happen
the soft Landscaping where the cemetery
land is will happen so it will be
grassed over and presumably those trees
will be planted but it's the hard
Landscaping of the roadway from the end
of the estate Road and the car park
which looks like it's got about eight
spaces eight or nine spaces for the
cemetery is not going to be completed at
the developers cost but it appears that
they are trying to negotiate with the
parish council
for them to pay costs
to the developer for them to install
that bit that's how I interpret it have
I got that right
but the other point about the transfer
of the the land to the parish council
that that
for the cemetery which the the transfer
of the land is also not secured that's
not so so there's two things that are
not secured the transfer of the land and
the the heart surfacing for the car park
yes
which is
what the parish council understood was
going to happen
uh Gemma yeah thank you chair
um just to say the
difficult one I appreciate that there is
that degree of what was expected and
potentially applied for what we secured
and what we're now looking at ultimately
we've got to be trading a careful line
of is it scale is it layout is it
landscape is it appearance
possibly some of those but also the fact
that nothing of this permission prevents
that happening and that's the critical
bit we might not have the details
Unfortunately they weren't secured you
know we can't go back but as long as
nothing here prevents or precludes you
within not a point of either being in
breach of any policy or causing harm by
doing so and that for me is the balance
of the consideration on that is we're
not precluding it we're not preventing
it
but it's not secured we can't also force
it to happen so that's the the contrary
on this position unfortunately
um with none of those points in the
reserve matters necessarily precludes it
from happening albeit I think you know
probably a fair degree of and you know
rightly so disappointment it hasn't
knitted together in the way we won't
normally expecting nowadays but it is on
the oldest side unfortunately we do see
some of those come too but hopefully
that helps with a little bit of the the
into directions before you
uh Council wall boys come back thank you
very much to the clinic so providers we
can't make it happen
uh but and it relies upon the Goodwill
of the developer and the agent at some
future point which it could happen
so could
could you have some indication of that
so possibly happening or
um I'll let Mr Shaw answer that
one of the meetings we had with the
parish council was about specific
arrangements for the transfer of this
land it's
it's to the parish council
so I don't think there's any intention
on landex but my clients to do anything
other than transfer this land to the
parish council
I'm sorry to finish the offer to
construct the road to construct the hard
landscaping area of the car parking area
at cost
still stands
does that does that help councilor War
boys yeah that seems to show a Way
Forward really thank you
um are there any further um anyone else
like to speak
um if not if I may just um ask a couple
of points I noticed in the conditions
um you've got
um EV charging details to be agreed
there are some
um dwellings that look like they don't
have car parking adjacent so will they
be supplied with the requirements for EV
charging and is there to be any EV
charging in the public Community car
park for the school and the church
as well
um in terms of the the EV charging I
don't believe there's
really too much of a situation where
each dwelling could not be provided with
one and because they have got allocated
spaces with parking court and obviously
it's to the frontage
of the house so it might be possible
that adapting or something could go in
um I don't believe there's any provision
in the section 106 for the EV charging
and car park specifically that's so that
that
be covered by this condition we could
obviously word it to cover it
um and I think that probably was
something that we could
easily do
um
yeah it might be worth asking the agent
if there's kind of any any specific
intention I mean obviously the the
outline the outline was was um
some time ago before EV charging was
important
um so you know a public car park
would be quite useful to have EV
charging
um you know it's for the school
someone might want to leave their car
there while they're at work
and charge it so um
that if it's reasonable to ask for that
to be considered that would be good
counselor having them
um well I think that um
it is what it is basically what we've
got in front of us you know regressible
no I think
sorry um did the agent want to come back
on the AV charging in the car park
I'd like to come back on the car park
per se and I've heard the term Community
car park used this is not a community
car park it is car parking for the
provision of staff at the school and for
the
it's not a community car park it is to
be the specification for the car park is
absolutely detailed in your own section
106 agreement I don't believe it
includes anything in relation to
electric vehicle charging points when it
was signed in December 2019.
so the important point is yes we'll
consider it but it's not part of that
concept it's not part of that
specification a barrier control is and
it's for that specific use the church
and the staff of the primary school it's
not a community car park
use the wrong term
I think they have different connotations
for hurtingham okay um yeah back to that
basically I was saying you know
you know with evidence to turn it down
and so I think the the offer to to the
parish and Council to put the hard hard
standing in which I mean that the hard
Landscaping in at cost is a reasonable
one and and so therefore heavy heart or
no I I'm gonna um recommend that we um
go along with officers approval and to
prove it
a second if that proposal Council Dave
does anyone want to make any further
comments
um if not the parish council one of the
other requests of the parish council I
think we've we've discussed the
variation of the section 106 and where
where we have been reassured that the
council is going to say no to that
um the construction management plan
which was the other Parish Council
request and I noticed there is a
construction management plan committee
condition
um can we add to that that the parish
council should be a party to any
discussion about that
yes I think we could put a note I kind
of appended to that condition
is that okay with the proposal and
seconder
no further comment so um if you can just
summarize what we are about to vote on
that would be helpful thank you
with additional conditions which I
believe were the place-based artificial
grass alternative to be agreed the EV
charges came to church school car park
to be agreed and construction management
plan to be undertaken in consultation
with the parish council by which we
would mean
prior to submission of the discharge the
consultation should have been undertaken
and then both parties would submit to us
yes we've talked we've talked and we
agreed so that it would be agreed in
advance I hope that was everything that
members one was one second
thank you I will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you members chair that's seven
votes four on one against therefore
that's carried
thank you
um I'd like to
um propose that we now have a lunch
break
um so it's now 20 to one
um
is uh meeting back at half past one
um acceptable so we've got like 50
minutes to take a break uh and then
we've got the the
um other remaining case the one in Elms
well
um after lunch and then we'll um have
further discussions
okay
and planning committee we now move to
item 9e DC 23
01076 Lantern north and west of School
Road elmswell Suffolk I will now invite
the case officer Dan camel to Cameron to
introduce their application to the
committee
thank you
um yeah um not all the committee members
will be familiar but I think this has
been in front of development control
committee twice once for the outline
um in 2018 and then once for the reserve
matters which was DC 2201615
um this is a section 73 a application
um so just to very briefly explain
section 73 it allows you to
modify or remove a planning condition
from a planning application
in this instance section 73a indicates
that the site is already commenced
and the application is for variation of
condition nine of the reserve and actors
on DC 22
01615 and that deals with noise
insulation on properties close to the
railway
which one I will quickly run through but
anyway for members who are not familiar
with the site
um plan we have now shows uh the
built-a-perry events well
to the west and further down here when
we zoom out we'll be able to see the
access down to the A14 and wool pit
this is a site we have
dwellings coming forward on the site as
well as provision of a
preschool which will come forward
through a separate application
if we Zoom slightly further out we have
the A14 curving along the bottom of the
screen and you get a much better idea of
how the site relates to the rest of
elm's world
as noted the application in outline and
Reserve mat has already come before
members and as you'll note from the
reports
determination that we make today won't
have any impact on the outline or the
reserved matters that's already been
granted that will still be able to go
ahead it just won't go ahead with the uh
the variation to the condition
this is the red line for the site it's
unchanged
um
from the outline
construction dropping I'm confuses
oh it shouldn't do
I think it's just the title of How It's
been saved
and then we come to the constraints map
so at the time of consideration for the
outline we were outside the settlement
Barons Reef rounds well however
has been approved we do have a grade two
listed building and onto our Hall over
the railway line to the north and we do
have some flood zone two and three
the west of the site however it doesn't
encroach into the site
if we look closer here we have the
railway line
along the north
and then it is these properties
that are subject to
the noise condition
this is the example Street Scene and
part of the street scene a is this
element along the north
overview of the units there as well
um so yeah so the units encased in
purple are the units that form part of
Zone a which is what the um
noise insulation condition relates to
and we also have the preschool outlined
in green which will be subject to its
own noise assessment at the time that
application comes forward
effectively
the condition as it's changed into our
in your reports and I hope that the red
text was acceptable for members it
dawned on me after we went to
publication that if any members are
colorblind that might not have been as
useful as I thought it was coloring it
red but effectively
the glazing is to
create a minimum Sound Reduction
performance which within this
application will be changed and slightly
increased but the passive ventilation on
those properties the noise reduction on
that will be slightly increased
um
as you'll see from the report
we've consulted with our environmental
health colleagues in terms of the noise
impact and they know that at the end of
the day the overall test is set out
in 0.5 which is unchanged that the
minimum level of noise reduction for
those properties must meet the levels
set out by the World Health Organization
and British standard
so on that basis he is content
to allow the variation of condition to
slightly increase
the decibel rating on the windows and
marginally
um
decrease on the Windows increase on the
passive ventilation
and this is a text copied from your
report With The Changes included and
this includes as well the point made in
the environmental health officers report
that says in the event that the
submitted information fails to satisfy
us in regards to the noise reduction
that we then look at a remedial scheme
with the applicant and we do not allow
occupation of those units while the
noise reduction within those units does
not meet who or British standard
um so members would have Clarity and
certainty that when we came to this
charger condition if we weren't able to
meet those minimum requirements there
wouldn't be any occupation of those
units within Zone a which would be
um you'll see from the site photos that
sites well Advanced it's Harris fenced
and
we've had implementation of the road
improvements
and now attention is turning within
within the site and changes to
that noise requirement
um so just to set out the recommendation
the recommendation in the report is our
set out there is no update via late
papers or table papers
consultation with the parish council
recommends that the decision is left
with our technical advisors who are
environmental health colleagues
environmental health officers consider
that there's no overall change in the
level of protection from noise that will
be
given to the future occupiers of those
dwellings by virtue of the changed
condition
and the condition wording ensures a
sufficient scope within the condition to
secure the evidence that the noise
insulation has been installed to the
level that we require it and if not that
we can remediate and improve on that
noise installation prior to occupation
so therefore the officer's
recommendation before members is to
approve the application are set out
meaning that we'd have the changed
Condition Nothing
members might also like to know that we
have had an extensive planning history
on this scheme and that relates to the
majority of discharge of conditions from
both the outline and the reserve matters
so when we turn to the end of the report
and you see the conditions set out
what we have done as officers is where
we already have discharge of condition
on other conditions we've set out that
those details that are appropriate get
carried forward here
I'll pass over to members for any
questions arising from the report and
let the meeting continue
questions for Dad Terry
very oh sorry
thank you thank you chair
um I question the uh not being that
technically minded on it but I do
question
um reducing from 43 decibels to only 39
how is that considered to be to maintain
the equivalent standard uh if the first
standard was acceptable for the original
application and it says a higher bar
and a better quality of life overall why
are we now
considering something that might meet
minimum standards it might meet BS
standards but the original higher level
possibly
was accepted in the original
response and that's what we approved why
are we now being asked to go lower
so in bringing forward the application
law at the time of the reserve matters
engaged in acoustic consultant to
undertake a report and set out their
requirements in terms of the noise
mitigation
as times progressed we now have a
updated report that um slightly tweaks
the way that those minimum who and
British standards are to be reached
um
in terms of consultation with
the environmental health officers
they're quite relaxed about the way in
which that overall reduction for the
property is engaged with in particular
if you think about
noise reduction from Windows that's only
affected if the windows are always
closed if the window is open the noise
reduction that occurs is then reduced so
in allowing slightly
um lesser noise reduction from the
windows but increasing it for the
passive ventilation
they consider that actually for most
times when you'd have the windows closed
most of the noise will be coming from
the passive ventilation anyway
so from that point of view they're happy
but also in terms of the standard the
overall standard that we're hoping to
hold the developer to isn't changing as
a result of this application so we'd
always be looking at The Who and British
standards regardless and I think from
their point of view how you reach that
endpoint
isn't material to them provided that you
can reach that end point and bear in
mind as well that it's a it's a minimum
standard so the noise reduction from the
windows and from the passive ventilation
is set as a minimum level if that needs
to be higher in order to meet The Who
and British standard then that is what
the developer will need to have a look
at but in this instance environmental
health officers are happy that those
decibel ratings will allow them to do
that but also the tweaks we've made to
the condition secure that if they can't
do that then we look at a remedial
scheme to improve noise installation on
those properties again so that we can
meet those who and British standard
minimum levels
thanks John oh sorry do you want to come
back uh yeah um yeah very minor I I
suspect
um I noticed that
oh sorry come back
Terry
yeah I'm afraid I'm just a little bit
cynical that you generate so or the
applicant generates one report
and then doesn't like the conditions
imposed on it so generates another
report to get conditions that he does
like and I'm just a bit cynical whether
that's the approach taken here
presumably applying these new standards
is saving the applicant money otherwise
he wouldn't be doing it
I'm just cynical that this is the basis
and it's always well with the
environmental officers saying they're
happy with it they don't have to live in
these houses
I take I take the point I think
in terms of the actual changes in noise
reduction they are quite small we aren't
looking at a a huge change in terms of
um
the minimum noise reduction that the
windows and the passive ventilation
needs to accomplish
um but at no point have we changed and
moved the goal posts in terms of the end
point that the noise insulation needs to
reach so that has been the same from
when we looked at the application it
reserves matters to now so that
ultimately will be
a test
for the revised acoustic solution that
is being brought forward here
ultimately does it meet who and British
standard where it does
then the properties are acceptable where
it doesn't then we have additional
remediation to go through and if that
requires additional noise insulation or
additional cost for the developer that
is their risk
John yeah I noticed the the the the the
the the you know the revised condition
refers to Zone a and the original one
referred to Zone one uh and I wonder if
it is is that a different or not
different no Zone one and Zone a it's
just I think it's just a quirk of
um whoever at the acoustic specialist
has labeled the plans I went through
them there was no change between Zone
one and Zone a we've always been dealing
with the same properties
if you have any other questions for
Daniel
okay we'll move on to the um public
speakers
um we haven't got anyone from the parish
council we haven't got an objector or
sport or the applicant but we do have um
Sarah Manson here as a ward member but
first of all we've got a statement from
counselor over it which um Claire's
going to read
thank you chair
please note that I support the officer
recommendation for approval noting that
the acoustic performance will be
equivalent or better than that
originally approved and that will be
tested prior to the homes being occupied
thank you
okay I'm Sarah thank you chair
um I'd just like to concur with with the
officer that this development has has
um been being developed at PACE uh the
photograph was taken while School Road
was shut a few months ago it is now all
complete we have the lovely new bike
path as far as the church beautiful
smooth surface people with their
mobility scooters uh whizzing up and
down because it's such a Pleasant View
the houses at the front are now being
marketed and I can also say that blore
have actually been quite a responsive
developer who have readily engaged with
the parish council and been responsive
to local concerns so
um although I understand councilor
counselor Matthew's concern about maybe
being a bit cynical they have actually
been quite cooperative
um and in actual fact I think I probably
agree with the officer's comment that
it's probably better to put more sound
insulation on the walls than on the
Windows because in times like this we
might all have the windows open uh so it
may be it may be beneficial to have more
of the attenuation on the walls
um and and the parish council
um decided that this was way too
technical for their Layman's knowledge
about sound attenuation that they
decided they didn't really want to make
any further comments
um this is quite a technical
um issue and provided the sound levels
are tested before these hazards are
occupied I don't really see it being a
major problem
um so I'm happy to support this
application
thank you does anyone have any questions
for Sarah
no okay well um we'll open up the item
for debate debate then who would like to
go first
come on John
all right well I I I I don't think there
are there are any any uh issues
um here at all and and so I'll propose
approval
in line with the office of
recommendations thank you very much
do I have a second to thank you Roland
would anyone like to speak at all
okay so we'll um I'll have to ask the
chief planning officer um slash area
planning manager to read out the
proposal on the table before we go to a
vote
thank you yeah we're just looking at
approving as the recommendation which is
set out on pages 128 and 129. thank you
but I will now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you members that vote is now in
progress for you
thank you members chair that is seven
votes for
it's carried
um right thanks very much
foreign
thank you
um I'd now like to
um move forward to item 10 on the agenda
which is site inspection
any site inspection requests need to be
reported to the committee
no chair not received
uh right so we're now going to go back
to item nine a
um which is the um
dc230218 land to the south of church
farm summersham ip8 4pn and land to the
east of the channel birthstone Suffolk
as advised earlier in the meeting we
will now need to agree to enter into
closed session to consider the legal
advice that we have received
um now I'm I'm prepared to propose this
that we exclude the public but I do need
to have a seconder
uh thank you councilor headingham
so sure sorry if I just may explain a
bit add a little bit of um
the advice is that well I'll just very
quickly go back to First principles
because I'm mindful that we don't do
this very often in planning committee
and
the the membership this committee is has
changed
it's a broad principle of local
government law that meetings are usually
in public unless there's a very good
reason for them not to be
law the law positively requires you to
exclude the public if you are
considering information given in
confidence by a government department or
by a third party who's given it under an
expectation of confidentiality that's
not the case here
but you have you may you have the right
and the discretion to exclude the press
and public in certain circumstances and
the list is now in schedule 12a of the
Local Government Act 1972 was amended
and it's been brought into line with
Freedom of Information law which you
will I know be familiar with and the
relevant exemption
which would apply in this case is number
five of schedule 12a which is the
information the information that you
would receive in in private is that is
information for which a claim for Legal
Professional privilege could be
maintained in legal proceedings this is
council's opinion on a planning appeal
that's not been resolved so that does
apply and this is for you to decide if
you if you wish to follow that
thank you for that clarification uh so
we now have a proposal and a second to
um uh go into a private session a closed
session so we'll carry out this vote by
a show of hands so all those in favor of
going into a closed session
thank you chair that's unanimous thank
you
um so we now need to um switch off the
uh